in this course you will learn about
microservice architecture and
distributed systems using a Hands-On
approach a microservices architecture is
a type of application architecture where
the application is developed as a
collection of services Giorgio from
Canton coding teaches this course he
does a great job teaching how to combine
a bunch of different Technologies into a
single application hey what's up
everybody and welcome to this video on
microservice architectures where we will
be applying this architecture to an
application that will convert video
files to MP3 files in this Hands-On
tutorial we'll be making use of python
rabbitmq mongodb Docker kubernetes and
MySQL to build this microservice
architecture which is admittedly a lot
but don't worry I'll walk you through
every step so let's go over what this
application is going to to look like
from a top-down perspective so when a
user uploads a video to be converted to
MP3 that request will first hit our
Gateway our Gateway will then store the
video in mongodb and then put a message
on this queue here which is our rapidm
queue letting Downstream Services know
that there is a video to be processed in
mongodb the video to MP3 converter
service will consume messages from the
queue it will then get the ID of the
video from the message pull that video
from mongodb convert the video to MP3
then store the MP3 on mongodb then put a
new message on the Queue to be consumed
by the notification service that says
that the conversion job is done the
notification service consumes those
messages from the queue and sends an
email notification to the client
informing the client that the MP3 for
the video that he or she uploaded is
ready for download the client will then
use a unique ID acquired from the
notification education plus his or her
JWT to make a request to the API Gateway
to download the MP3 and the API Gateway
will pull the MP3 from mongodb and serve
it to the client and that is the overall
conversion flow and how rapid mq is
integrated with the overall system okay
so the first thing that we're going to
need to do before we get started with
writing any code or setting up any of
our services is we're going to need to
install a few things now the Links for
all of these pages are going to be in
the description and it's critical that
we correctly install all of these
prerequisites prior to moving forward
with the course so please take the time
to make sure that you've correctly
installed all of these things so to
start we're going to install Docker and
I'm using Max so everything that I do
like everything that I install is going
to be for Mac so if you have Windows or
a Linux system you're going to need to
do some additional research to figure
out how to install on those platforms
because I'm not going to spend the time
diving too deep into that but if you're
able to successfully install everything
on this list then that's probably one of
the most difficult parts of this course
and the rest of it should be a pretty
smooth sailing so to start we're going
to install Docker so I would hit this
install Docker desktop and I'm using an
M1 MacBook Pro so I would install with
apple chip if you're using an Intel
MacBook Pro or MacBook then you would
use the Intel chip installation and of
course you're just going to click the
link and install it that way
and following the successful
installation of Docker you should be
able to do Docker version and get a
Docker version here now once you've
gotten Docker installed we'll move on to
installing the kubernetes manline tool
and as you can see the kubernetes
command line tool allows you to run
commands against kubernetes clusters and
we're going to be deploying our services
within a kubernetes cluster so that's
why we need this command line tool so
again I'm going to choose to install for
Mac
and there are a couple of options to
install for Mac you can use Homebrew or
you can install the binary using curl I
believe I installed the binary using
curl and I selected the Apple chip and I
just ran this command
and I didn't validate the binary
but you do have to make the binary
executable by running this command
and of course you're going to need to
move the binary to a location that's
within your path now I'm not going to
get into details on how to do this this
documentation is pretty detailed and
installing binaries and adding them to
your path isn't within the scope of this
video so if that's a little bit too
advanced for you you can just use the
Homebrew installation which pretty much
automates all of this for you
and once you've finished with the
installation you should be able to type
Cube CTL or cube cuddle or whatever you
like to call it
and if you type that you should get the
output that provides information about
this command line utility
now following the installation of
cubecto you can move on to installing
minicube and minicube is a local
kubernetes focusing on making it easy to
learn and develop for kubernetes so
basically this is going to allow us to
have a kubernetes cluster on our local
machine so this way we can make a
microservice architecture on our local
machine without having to actually have
a kubernetes cluster deployed to like a
production environment or something like
that so this goes on to explain the
requirements to use minicube
and the installation instructions are
here and you're just going to select for
your operating system so I would select
Mac OS and I would select arm 64 as the
architecture and of course we'll select
stable and I used the binary download
for this one as well but again if you're
not familiar with how to install
binaries and configure your path just go
with the Homebrew installation
and then once it's installed we should
be able to start a cluster from our
local machine
and your Cube CTL will automatically be
configured to work with mini cubes so
you don't need to do anything there so
once mini cube is installed you should
be able to do mini Cube start
and everything should start up for you
and there's actually another thing that
I forgot to add to the list of what we
need to install so we're going to
install this K9s
and we're just going to use this to sort
of help manage our kubernetes cluster so
the installation instructions for this
are just here in the documentation you
can just do Brew install canines of
course if you're on Mac but of course
they have the installation instructions
for other operating systems as well so
just figure out which one of these is
best for you
and once you've finished installing
canines you should be able to type
canines in the command line interface
and it should pull up our cluster which
is just our mini Cube cluster which you
can see here and you can quit by just
using Ctrl C
and let's go ahead and clear this now
the next thing that we're going to need
to install is python3 more specifically
because we're going to use Python 3 to
create our first service a very simple
authentication Service and all of these
services are going to be relatively
simple because the focus of this
tutorial isn't necessarily the services
but how all of the services
intercommunicate and how a distributed
system is integrated as a whole so we're
not going to spend too much time on
creating large services for this
microservice architecture anyways to
download python if you don't already
have it you're just going to select for
Mac of course you're just going to
select this button here and just follow
the installation instructions from there
and lastly we're going to need to
install MySQL because this is going to
be the database that we use for our auth
service so I installed MySQL using
Homebrew so you can just do Brew install
MySQL so let's just go ahead and copy
this
and we can just paste it
now as you can see here it says we've
installed your mySQL database without a
root password and to secure it run
mysql's secure installation but we're
not going to do any of this because
again that's not the focus of this
tutorial so yeah in a production
environment you're going to want to make
sure you're securing your MySQL
installation and you're going to want to
follow all of the best security
practices when working with and
installing a database server but in our
case we're just going to leave the
installation the way it is which again
isn't something that you're going to
want to do in a production environment
this is just so that we can get to the
actual meat and potatoes of the tutorial
so we can access our mySQL database by
just running MySQL with the user root
and we don't even need a password so we
should just be able to do MySQL U root
and this will give us access to the
database
and I think that's it for the things
that we need to install for now we're
probably going to need to install some
more things later but for our first
service I think that that's all that we
need so as mentioned before we're going
to start with our auth service that's
going to be this first service that we
create and deploy to our cluster on our
local environment and just quick note
everything's going to be deployed on our
local environment in our mini Cube
cluster we're not going to deploy
anything to a server I might create
another tutorial on how to actually
deploy this to a server or to a
production like environment but for now
we're only focused on the actual
architecture so everything's going to be
done on our local system within this
mini Cube cluster so to start we're
going to want to create a directory so
we'll make dur and we'll call this dir
maybe something like system design
and we'll just go ahead and change
directory into this system design
directory and we're going to be writing
code for multiple services and actually
all of the services are going to be
written in Python and if you aren't
familiar with python don't worry I
explained enough when writing the code
where it shouldn't really matter which
language you're most comfortable with
and since we're focused on the
architecture as a whole we're not
necessarily going to be writing any
complicated code anyway so anyways we're
going to make a directory for Python and
this is going to contain our python
services and we'll put a source
directory but we don't need a bin
directory so we can just do let's just
make a python directory change directory
to python
make directory source
So within this system design python
Source directory we're going to create
the directory for our auth service so
we'll make their auth and this author is
going to contain our auth service code
so let's CD auth
and from here to start we're going to
want to create a virtual environment
and we're going to write all of the code
for the service in one file that we're
going to call server.pi and the reason
we're doing this in one file is because
it's going to be less than 700 lines of
code and like I said before the service
is going to be relatively small it's
just going to be a very simple auth
service and actually I forgot to
activate our virtual environment so
let's go ahead and do that and we should
see that our virtual environment is
running if we run this command here and
I'm going to need to install a couple of
things for my Vim configuration I'll go
ahead and install pylent
and pip install Jedi let's just go ahead
and run this command that they're
suggesting to upgrade pip
and let's open server.pi and the start
of our file is just going to be to
import JWT which is Json web token and
we're going to get into why we're
importing that soon we're going to
import date time and Os and we're also
going to import from flask
import flask and request and we're also
going to import from flask
mysqldb Imports
my SQL so basically this is going to
allow us to query our mySQL database
this is going to be our actual server
we're going to be using flask to create
our server and this is going to be what
we're going to use for our actual auth
we're going to use Json web tokens and
date time is so that we can set an
expiration date on our token and Os is
just going to be used so that we can use
environment variables to configure our
MySQL connection and you will see what I
mean by that soon
so let's just go ahead and save this and
we're going to need to install a couple
of things so let's just cat server.pi so
we can see what we need to install and
then we can just do pip install I
believe JWT is like Pi JWT
and we're going to need to pip install
flask
and pip install flask MySQL DB
and we can open this file back up again
and to start we're just going to create
a server which is just going to be a
flask object
so we're going to instantiate this flask
object and we're going to create a MySQL
object which is going to be an instance
of this MySQL which we passed the server
now for the purposes of this video we
don't necessarily need to understand the
magic Behind These two lines of code
here
if we go ahead and save this and we go
to the definition here we can get a
general understanding of what this flask
object is doing but the main thing that
we need to be concerned with is once it
is created it will act as a central
registry for the view functions the URL
rules template configuration and much
more so basically this is just going to
configure our server so that requests to
specific routes can interface with our
code and this MySQL object is basically
just going to make it so that our
application can connect to our mySQL
database and basically query the
database so following this we're going
to want to set up our config so our
server object has a config attribute
which is essentially a dictionary which
we can use to store configuration
variables so for example we can set the
configuration for our MySQL host
and we can set it equal to OS dot
environ.get which is just going to get
the MySQL host from our environment so
what do I mean by that so if we save
this and we do export MySQL host equals
localhost and we go into server.pi
this code here this OS dot environ.get
MySQL host is going to resolve to
localhost that we set in our environment
within our shell so if we were to go and
print this
server.config
MySQL host
and if we were to just Python 3
server.pi
you'd see that it prints out the Local
Host that we set in our environment
variable
So This Server is our application
and server.config is just the
configuration for our server or our
application
so we're going to create a couple of
these
all with different variables of course
so this one's going to be
MySQL user
and the same here for the environment
and this one will be MySQL password
and this one would be MySQL DB
and MySQL
port
and we don't need that one so this is
going to be the configuration for our
application and these are going to be
the variables that we use to connect to
our mySQL database and the next thing
that we want to do is create our first
route
which is going to have the path login
and the methods for login are just going
to be post
and this route is going to route to this
function login
and we can just write the code for the
login function we're going to set off a
variable called auth equal to request
dot authorization
and this request is the request that
we're importing here and with this
authorization attribute provides is the
credentials from a basic authorization
header so when we send a request to this
login route we're going to need to
provide a basic authorization header
which will contain essentially a
username and a password and this request
object has an attribute that gives us
access to that so once we instantiate
this object we'd be able to do
auth.username to get the username from
the basic authorization header and
auth.password to get the password from
the basic authorization header
and you'll see what I mean when we send
the actual request but if we don't
provide that header within the request
then this auth is going to be none so
that means that the request is going to
be invalid so we're going to do if not
off so if the header doesn't exist
within the request we're going to return
missing credentials and we're going to
turn a status 401 which is just the
standard status code that we would
return in this case
and the next thing that we're going to
do is we're just going to check DB for
username and password
so the way that this login route is
going to work is basically we're going
to check a database so this off service
is going to have its own mySQL database
and we're going to check a user table
within that database which we're going
to create and the user table should
contain a username and password for the
users that are trying to log in or
trying to access the API so actually
before we do this part we want to go
ahead and create a database and a user
table and a user that we can use to
access the API so we'll go ahead and
save this and let's just clear and we
just want to go ahead and create a file
called
init.sql So within this file we're
basically going to create a user for our
auth service and we're going to give
that user a username and a password and
then we're going to create a database a
mySQL database called auth which is
going to be the database for our auth
service and we're going to Grant the
user that we create privileges to the
database and we're going to create a
table within that database called user
not to be mistaken with the user that
we're creating within the mySQL database
and that user table is going to be what
we use to store users that we want to
give access to our API and I know I'm
using the word user a lot and the users
that I'm mentioning here aren't
interchangeable so let's just go ahead
and get into it so I can show you what I
mean so first we want to create user now
this user is the user for our actual
database so this isn't the user that
we're trying to give access to our API
and we're just going to call it auth
user because it's the user for the auth
service to access our database
and we're going to say identified by and
we're going to give it a simple password
auth123
so this here is creating the user to
access the mySQL database so this isn't
the user to access the API this is a SQL
script so we're basically just writing
out some SQL queries and statements in
this script to build our database
essentially so then we want to create
database
and we're going to call the database off
and we want to give this user up here
access to the auth database and all of
its tables so we're going to do Grant
all
privileges on off and all tables to
auth user which is the user that we just
created at localhost
and we want to use the auth database
when we create the table and then we'll
create a table called user
and the primary key is just going to be
ID int not null Auto increment
primary key
and actually there's a typo here
Auto increment and the next column is
going to just be email and it's going to
be varchar and we'll just put the
maximum 255 not null
and lastly we're going to have a
password which is again a parchar
and we'll just allow it to be long
and after we create the table we just
want to insert the user that we're going
to use to test our application
so we're going to say I'm going to give
the user an email and a password
and the values are going to be
I'll just use my name you can use yours
if you want or whatever
admin123 for the password
and can't forget this in my colon so
so this is going to create our initial
user
or the user that will represent our auth
service so basically we're going to use
this credential to access the database
via our auth service and then we're
going to create the database
and then we're going to Grant
permissions for our auth service to make
changes to this auth service database
and we're going to go ahead and create
the table here as well as our initial
user
and this is going to be the user that
goes into the database which will have
access to our off service API
so we can just go ahead and save that
and now we can just go ahead and run
this script to create our initial
database
so just before we do that we'll just go
ahead and
go into our database and we can do show
databases here and you'll see that we
don't have the auth database yet
so we can go ahead and exit that and
clear and now we're going to do the same
thing that we would do to log in but
this time we're just going to pass in
our init.sql file and it appears we have
an error in our syntax near Auto
increment primary key
so let's go ahead and go back in here
and I spelled increment wrong
should be increment
and let's just try that again
and actually it's failing now because
just now when we try to run the script
the first time it already created the
user but then the script failed so we
already have this user so it's trying to
create the same user again so let's just
go ahead and delete their user
drop database auth as well
and drop
user
so now we dropped the database and we
dropped the user that we created in that
script because we want the whole script
to run not just part of it so we can go
ahead and clear this and let's just run
it one more time so on SQL
you root
innate.sql and the script ran
successfully
so let's go in here
and show databases and you can see now
that we have this auth database and if
we use auth
and we show tables
you can see that we have this user table
and we can also describe user and it
shows all of the fields for the user
table which include the primary key
which is the ID the email and the
password and we can even select all from
user
oops
select all from user and you see that we
have the one user that we created in the
script I named it my name for the email
and admin123 for the password you can do
whatever you want for this part as long
as you make sure to use those
credentials when you actually try to
make requests to our API
so we can go ahead and exit that and now
we can go back into writing our code for
our server.pi file so here we're going
to check the DB for the username and the
password that we pass in our basic
authorization header in our request to
this login endpoint and we're going to
do that by making use of this flask
MySQL DB here so this is basically just
going to allow us to interface with our
mySQL database
and that's why we added this application
config here which has all of the
configuration variables to connect to
the database that we just created
and we're going to need to set
environment variables for our host and
our user and our password in our
database which are all things that we
just created
and our host is going to be localhost
and the port is going to be the default
port for MySQL
so we'll go here and we're going to
create a cursor by doing
mysql.connection.cursor
and we're going to use that cursor to
execute queries so we're going to say
the result of the query is going to be
equal to
cursor.execute and within this execute
method we're going to put in our query
so we can just do it this way
so we'll do select email we want to
select the email and the password from
our user table where
email
equals
whatever email is getting passed in the
request
so we're going to do off we're going to
take it from that alt dictionary or
object we're going to take the username
and we need to pass it in as a tuple
so remember this auth object here gives
us access to the username and the
password from the basic authorization
header
so what we're doing here is we're
selecting from our user table in our
auth database the email that's equal to
the username that's passed into this
basic authorization header so we're
going to be using email for our username
and if the user exists within our
database then we should have a result so
if result is greater than zero because
results going to be an array of rows I
believe so if result is greater than
zero then that means that we have at
least one row with that username and in
this situation we should only have one
row with that username because the
username should be unique but actually I
forgot to set the column for the
username to be unique so maybe we should
go ahead and do that
so we should be able to just go over
here and add unique for the email and
then save it and once again we need to
drop our database
we're going to drop the user
and we're also going to drop the
database
and now once again we can run MySQL U
root init.sql okay so back into our
server.pi file
so anyways at this point if resulted is
greater than zero then that means the
user exists within our database
and if that's the case we're going to
set the row that contains our user data
to
cursor.fetch one
and this is basically going to resolve
to a tuple which is going to contain our
email so we'll do user row 0 that's
going to be the email and our password
which is going to be
user Row one
and next we just want to check to see if
the username and the password returned
in the row is equal to the credentials
passed in the request and if that's not
the case we'll say that the credential
is invalid and if it is the case then
we're going to return a Json web token
so we'll say if auth.username not equal
to email or auth.password because we
need both of them to be equal to
what we get from the database not equal
to password then if that's the case
we're going to return invalid
credentials and we're going to return a
401 status code
else will return and we're going to
create this function we haven't created
it yet but we'll return the results of
the function called create JWT and in
this function we'll pass the auth
username and we'll need to pass in a
secret for the JWT so we'll just have
that in our environment
and we'll just call it JWT Secret
and we're going to pass in true and I'll
get to what this means in a second but
we're not creating this create JWT
function yet so just bear with me for a
bit and lastly we get to
if result is not greater than zero so if
result's not greater than zero then that
means the user doesn't exist in our
database and if the user doesn't exist
in our database then that means the user
doesn't have access so we'll just return
invalid credentials as well for this one
and a 401.
and that is going to be it for our login
route and the login function so now we
want to go ahead and create this create
JWT method or create JWT function
actually so I'm going to go ahead and
explain a little bit about what a JWT
actually is first so we're going to go
over the overall flow using basic
authentication and jwts and I will try
to clear up any compiled confusion that
you might have up to this point in the
tutorial so let's visualize the flow
from a top-down perspective to get an
overall understanding of what our code
is doing so as mentioned before our
micro services are going to be running
in a kubernetes cluster and that
clusters internal network is not going
to be accessible to or from the outside
world or the open internet our client is
going to be making requests from outside
of the cluster with the intention of
making use of our distributed system
deployed within our private kubernetes
cluster via our systems Gateway so our
Gateway service is going to be the entry
point to the overall application and the
Gateway service is going to be the
service that receives requests from the
client and it is also going to be the
service that communicates with the
necessary internal services to fulfill
the requests received from the client
our Gateway is also going to be where we
Define the functionality of our overall
application for example if we want to
add functionality to upload a file we
need to Define an upload endpoint in our
Gateway service source that initiates
all of the necessary internal services
to make that happen so if our internal
Services live within a private Network
how do we determine when we should allow
requests in from the open internet this
is where our auth service comes in we
can give clients access to our
application by creating credentials for
them with in our office database any
user password combination that exists
within our MySQL DBS user table is a
user password combination that will be
granted access to our application's
endpoints this is where the
authentication scheme called basic
authentication or basic access
authentication comes in this
authentication scheme requires the
client to provide a username and
password in their request which should
be contained within a header field of
the form authorization basic credentials
where credentials is the base64 encoding
of the username and password joined by a
single colon in the context of our off
flow we are going to make use of this
authentication scheme by taking the
username and password from the
authorization header when a client sends
a request to our login endpoint and
comparing them to what we have in our
mysqldb if we find a match for the
credentials we know that the user has
access so we will return a Json web
token to the client which the client
will use for subsequent requests to our
gateways upload and download endpoints
which brings us to the other critical
part of our off flow Json web tokens so
what are Json web tokens a Json web
token is basically just two Json
formatted strings and a signature which
comprise three parts each part being
base64 encoded all three parts are
merged together separated by a single
dot which is how we end up with
something that looks like this but let's
break this down so what are these three
parts well the first part is the header
the header contains a key value pair for
both the signing algorithm and the type
of token which is of course JWT the
signing algorithm is the algorithm that
was used to sign the token which will
allow us to later verify that the sender
of the token is who it says it is and to
ensure that the message wasn't changed
along the way now there are both
asymmetric signing algorithms with two
keys a public and private key and there
are symmetric signing algorithms which
use just one private key we aren't going
to go into detail about signing
algorithms because it is not within the
scope of this course but what you do
need to know is that our auth service is
going to be using the symmetric signing
algorithm
hs-256 for example our auth service is
going to be the only entity that knows
our single private key and when a user
logs in using basic auth or auth service
will create a JWT or Json web token and
sign it using that private key that JWT
will then be returned to the user or the
client that way when the user makes
following requests to our API it will
send its JWT in the requests and our
auth service can validate the token
using the single private key if the
token has been tampered with in any way
or was signed using another key then our
auth service will know that the token is
invalid it's important that we know that
the Json formatted data in the token
hasn't been tampered with because that
data is going to contain the access
permissions for the user so without this
signing algorithm if the client were to
alter the Json data and upgrade its
permissions to increase its permissions
allowing itself access to resources that
shouldn't be available to that
particular user then at that point our
entire system would be compromised this
brings me to the next part of our JWT
the payload the payload contains the
claims for the user or the bearer of the
token what are claims you ask or maybe
you didn't ask but I'll explain it
anyway simply put claims are just pieces
of information about the user for the
most part these claims are defined by us
although there are predefined claims as
well for things like the issuer of the
token the expiration of the token Etc
the claims that we're going to Define on
our own are who the user is for example
the username and whether or not the user
has admin privileges which in our case
is just going to be true or false now
the last part of the token is the
signature the signature is created by
taking the base64 encoded header the
encoded payload and our private key and
signing them using the signing algorithm
which would in our case be hs256 at the
end of all this we are left with a token
that looks like this and now whenever
the client makes requests to our API and
provides this token within the request
we can determine if the client's token
was indeed signed with our private key
and our signing algorithm and if so we
can determine the client's access level
by checking the claims in the payload
portion of the token so in our case
we're simply going to allow the client
access to all of our endpoints if a
claim that we're going to call admin has
a value of true when we decode the
payload portion of the token and that's
going to be our off flow so we're going
to Define and create JWT and it's going
to take in a username a secret
and auth's
and auth is just going to tell us
whether or not the user is an
administrator so we're going to keep the
permissions simple we're going to either
have true or false either the user is an
administrator or the user isn't an
administrator
and this is just going to return JWT dot
encode now this JWT comes from up here
we're importing this JWT here and it's
from this Pi JWT module
So within this in code we're going to
need to pass a dictionary containing our
claims a secret and an algorithm so
we'll start with the dictionary
it's going to contain username and the
username is going to be the username
that we pass into the function and it's
going to have expiration and expiration
is going to be date time dot date time
dot now and time zone is going to be
equal to date time Dot
timezone.utc
and we'll just continue this on the next
line and we're going to add that to date
time dot time Delta
days
equals one
this is just going to set the expiration
of this token to one day so this token
is going to expire in 24 hours
and this IAT is just issued at so like
this is when the token is issued so
we're just going to do date time
date time
UTC now
and actually we could have done the same
thing above for it now but we'll just
leave it
and then we're going to have whether or
not this user is an administrator
and that's just going to be
the bull that we pass here for alts
and next we need to pass in the secret
and we also need to pass in the
algorithm and this is basically just the
signing algorithm for our JWT
and we'll just use hs256
which I believe is the default but a
little verbosity never hurt anybody
so actually
so now we have our login route and our
login function and we have the function
to create the Json web token
so essentially the flow is going to be a
user is going to make a request to our
login route using his or her credentials
a username and a password and then we're
going to check to
see if that user data exists within our
database if it does then we can consider
the user to be authenticated and we'll
return a Json web token which is going
to be used by that user to make requests
to the API and the endpoints that that
user will have access to will be
determined by this permissions here so
whether or not the user is an admin
we're going to keep it simple if the
user is an admin will make the user have
access to all the endpoints and yeah
that's going to be the flow for logging
in so we also need to create an endpoint
for this auth service to actually
validate the jwts
so the way that we're going to do it is
we're going to basically we're using
this secret when we create the JWT and
that same secret is going to be used to
actually decode the token as well so
that's how we know that this is a valid
token for our API okay so while we're
down here let's just go ahead and
configure our entry point so we'll just
do if name equals Main and all this
means is basically when we run this file
using the python command then this name
variable will resolve to Main
so let's just leave here and clear this
so if we do Python 3 server.pi whenever
we run this file this way the name
variable resolves to Main
so if we go back in here
we can actually just print name
and if we run this we'll see that the
result is Main
so that's all this is for so whenever we
run our file using the python command we
want our server to start so we'll do
server run and we want our server to run
on Port 5000 and we want to configure
the host parameter like so which
essentially is going to allow our
application to listen to any IP address
on our host
so essentially if we don't set this host
parameter like so the default is going
to be localhost which means that our API
wouldn't be available externally
and as you can see here in this flask
documentation configuring our host
parameter this way tells our operating
system to listen on all public IPS
otherwise the server is only accessible
from our own computer or from localhost
so let me try to explain what I mean by
that so basically any server is going to
need an IP address to allow access from
outside of the server so in our case our
server would be a Docker container and
our application will be running within
that container when we spin up our
Docker container it will be given its
own IP address we can then use that IP
address to send requests to our Docker
container which in this case is our
server and keep in mind when I'm
referring to an IP address assigned to a
Docker container I'm referring to the IP
address assigned to that container
within a Docker Network so when we spin
up our Docker container it will be given
its own IP address and we can use that
IP address to send requests to our
Docker container which in this case is
our server but that alone isn't enough
to enable our flask application to
receive those requests we need to tell
our flask application to listen on our
container's IP address so that when
request gets into our containers IP our
application can receive those requests
so this is where the host config comes
in the host is the server that is
hosting our application in our case the
server that is hosting our flask
application is the docker container that
it is running in so we need to tell our
flask app to listen on our Docker
containers IP address but a Docker
container's IP address is subject to
change so instead of setting it to the
static IP address of our Docker
container we set it to this
0.0.0.0 IP address which is kind of like
a wild card that tells our our flask app
to listen on any and all of our Docker
containers IP addresses that it can find
if we don't configure this it will
default to just localhost which is the
loopback address and localhost is only
accessible from within the host
therefore outside requests sent to our
Docker container would never actually
make it to our flask app because the
loopback address isn't publicly
accessible so when we set host to
0.0.0.0 we are telling our flask app to
listen on all of our Docker containers
IPS including the loopback address or
localhost and any other IP address
available on the docker container for
example if we connect our Docker
container to two separate Docker
networks Docker will assign a different
IP address to our container for each
Docker Network that means that with the
0.0.0.0 host configuration our flask app
will listen to requests coming to both
of the IP addresses assigned to the
container here it's also possible to set
the host config to a specific IP address
that way our flask app will only listen
to requests going to that IP address and
would no longer listen to requests going
to localhost or the other IP address
from the other Docker Network
so now that we've finished creating our
login route we want to actually create
another route to validate jwts
and this route is going to be used by
our API Gateway to validate jwt's synth
within request from the client to both
upload and receive or download MP3s or
to upload videos and download the MP3
version of those videos and you'll see
what I mean by that later on in the
tutorial when we actually start to
implement that so we're going to do
another route and this one's going to be
validate
and methods are going to be
post
and we're going to define a function
called validate
and we're going to want to pull the
encoded JWT from our request and we're
going to require the JWT to be in a
headers or a header called authorization
and if the JWT is not present in the
authorization header we want to return
an error
so we'll say encoded JWT if not encoded
JWT we'll just return missing
credentials
and a 401
so if you remember from the explanation
of the basic authentication scheme for
that scheme we would need to have the
word basic in our authorization header
that contained our base64 encoded
username and password separated by a
colon well for our JWT we instead need
to have the word Bearer in the
authorization header that includes the
token so let me quickly go over the
format for the authorization header so
that you understand what's happening so
if we look at the documentation for
authorization headers on mozilla.org we
see that the format for the header is
first type and then credentials here
type represents the authentication
scheme and credentials represents the
credentials necessary specific to that
type so from the perspective of the
server handling the authorization header
the type tells us what type of
credential is contained within the
header so if the type is basic from the
server perspective we know that we are
dealing with a credential which is a
base64 encoded username and password
separated by a colon if the type is
Bearer we know that we are dealing with
a bearer token which essentially means
that we can assume the party in
possession of the token or the bearer of
the token has access to the tokens
Associated resources now in the code for
our validation endpoint to save some
time we're just going to assume the
authorization header contains a bearer
token therefore we aren't going to check
or validate the word that represents the
type that comes before the credential in
the header but in an actual production
environment you are definitely going to
want to spend the extra time to check
the type or the authentication scheme
present within the authorization header
and within this authorization header
we're going to require the token to be
formatted as bear authentication so
basically we're going to want the header
that's synt with the JWT to look like
this so it's going to have this Bearer
as part of the string and then the token
and as a result of that if the encoded
JWT is present we're going to need to
split the string so we're going to set
encoded JWT equal to encoded JWT dot
split and we're going to need to split
it based on a space because there's
going to be the word bear
and then a space and then there's going
to be the token so the array that
results from this split is going to have
the item with the word bear and it's
going to have an element with the token
so we're going to need the first index
or the item at the first index of the
array not the zero
and then we're going to try and we're
going to do decoded equals JWT dot
decode
and to this decode method we're going to
need to pass the encoded JWT and we also
need to pass our JWT secret the one that
was used when we actually encoded the
JWT which is going to be in an
environment variable
and we're also going to need the
algorithm and the algorithm that we used
was hs256
and if that fails
we're just going to return not
authorized
and a 403. but if it doesn't fail we
will return the decoded token
and a 200. and that's pretty much going
to be it for our auth service so we can
just
go ahead and save this
so now we have our actual service and we
have our init script for our database
and now we're going to need to start
writing all of our infrastructure code
for the actual deployment so we're
basically going to deploy all of our
services within a kubernetes cluster as
you already know so we need to create
Docker images that we're going to push
to a repository and our kubernetes
configuration is going to pull from the
repositories for our Docker images and
create our deployments within our
cluster and I know that this sounds kind
of confusing but we're going to walk
through everything step by step so don't
worry so we're going to start by making
a Docker file and as our base image we
want to use a python image so we'll use
this python 310 slim bullseye
and after we write out this Docker file
I'll go over what all the lines mean in
a little bit more detail but for now I'm
just going to vaguely go over what we're
doing so first we're going to run our
apt-get update
and we also need to apt-kit install a
couple of dependencies
so we're going to need build Essentials
and default
live MySQL
client Dev
and then we want to pip install upgrade
pip
and following that we want to set our
working directory to app and we want to
copy first just our requirements dot txt
which we haven't created yet
and the reason we're copying this
separately from the rest of the
application is because we want to make
sure our requirements are in a separate
layer so that if our application code
changes we can still use the cached
requirements layer we don't need to
reinstall or recreate the layer and I'll
probably explain that in a little bit
more detail later on
so then we want to run pip install our
requirements
and then we can copy over the rest of
our application
and our app is going to be running on
Port 5000 so we'll expose that port and
finally we need to create the command
which is going to be python3
server.pi
so it's the same as when we're actually
running this python3 server.pi from the
command line
and that is it for that so we'll save
that now let's get into explaining the
contents of our Docker file so basically
when we build a Docker image we're
building it on top of a base image which
in our case is this base image python
310 slim Bullseye so we can think of an
image as a file system snapshot for
example the base image that we are
building our image on top of is
essentially a snapshot of a file system
that contains all of the necessary
dependencies to run python applications
for instance we wouldn't be able to run
a DOT Pi file on an OS that doesn't have
python installed right so a base python
image will have things pre-installed so
that we don't need to worry about that
so based on that understanding let's go
a little deeper it's important to keep
in mind when writing Docker files that
each instruction in a Docker file
results in a single New Image layer
being created that means that the next
instructions image layer will be built
on top of the previous instructions
image layer so that means that this from
instruction creates a layer and then
this run instruction creates a new layer
on top of the previous layer that was
built from the from instruction and this
continues on until we reach the end of
our Docker file this is important to
understand because if we need to build
our Docker image again Docker is smart
enough to use cached image layers if
nothing within the layer has changed and
none of its preceding layers have
changed so what do I mean by that so
let's say that the dependencies for our
application change resulting in our
requirements.txt file changing when we
rebuild the image we won't need to
rebuild every layer again we only need
to rebuild the layer that changes and
every layer after it because of course
every layer after it is based on its
preceding layer therefore if the
preceding layer changes so does it and
the reason it's important to understand
this is because optimizing your Docker
file to use cached layers efficiently
will significantly decrease the build
time of your image and that might not
seem so beneficial in this context but
when we are talking about deploying
production applications using CI CD
pipelines the build speed is something
that we want to consider now if you
don't know what a CI CD pipeline is
don't worry it's not necessary to
understand that for this tutorial
anyways with the understanding that each
instruction results in its own layer and
that if one layer changes every layer
after that layer will also need to be
rebuilt we can see why it's beneficial
to separate the copy instructions for
our requirements.txt from the copy
instructions of the rest of our
application because with this
configuration as you can see if the
dependencies for our application change
resulting in our requirements.txt file
changing we need to create a new layer
to build onto with the new requirements
being installed in this run pip install
layer and of course every layer after
that layer will need to be rebuilt as
well but if we only make a code change
and our requirements don't change we
don't want to have to build the layer
that installs our dependencies again
because this is probably one of the most
time consuming layers to build so as you
can see we are copying the rest of our
application to the app directory here
and by the way this dot just means the
current directory that we ran the docker
builds command in so if we copy dot to
our app directory which is our working
directory or copying everything in the
directory where we ran the docker build
command in on our local machine in other
words the directory that contains our
Docker file on our local machine and if
any of the code has changed since our
source files are contained within that
directory Docker will detect that there
was a change and rebuild this layer and
every layer following this layer will
need to be rebuilt as well but as you
can see the layers following this layer
don't include the time consuming pip
install command so that's just a quick
example of why optimizing your Docker
file to be more layer efficient is
beneficial so now back to the rest of
our instructions so after we build our
base layer using the python 310 slim
Bullseye image we then move on to
installing our OS dependencies and all
of these flags in purple here are to
avoid installing unnecessary additional
packages as well as avoiding taking up
additional space with caching and stuff
like that because we want our container
to be as light as possible and we also
don't want to introduce potential
vulnerabilities present on packages that
we don't even need and the reason we are
combining all of these commands into one
command is so that we can keep them all
in the same run instruction therefore
keeping them contained to one image
layer because remember every Docker
instruction creates a new image layer
and then here we're just creating a
directory to work in and this dirt is
where our application source is going to
live and these instructions we've
already gone over and this expose
instruction doesn't actually do much of
anything other than serve as
documentation to anybody that builds
this image and it essentially lets them
know what port is intended to be
published so our app listens on Port
5000 so that is the port that we have
here in the expose instruction and
lastly we have our Command instruction
and this instruction is the instruction
that is going to be used to run our
container this instruction sets the
command to be executed when running the
image so for example when we run our
image the Python 3 command will be run
on our server.pi file which is going to
run our auth server in this case
okay now let's go ahead and build this
Docker file
oh and I forgot to create our
requirements.txt so we're going to do uh
pip 3 freeze and we're going to freeze
our requirements the current
requirements for our application into a
file called requirements.txt and if we
go into this file you see it has all of
the requirements that we needed to
install for our application like it has
this MySQL DB that we're using and of
course flask and any of their
dependencies as well
so doing pip 3 freeze it basically
freezes our dependencies into a file so
that we know what dependencies we need
to install to run this application
so let's go ahead and try this again
and now it says unable to locate package
build Essentials so let's go back into
our Docker file and that is a typo it's
actually just build essential
and let's try again
foreign and now our image is finished
being built so once we've finished
building our image we actually want to
create a Docker registry or a repository
so you can just go to hub.docker.com
and create an account here I already
have an account so I will just sign in
okay so once you've successfully created
an account and logged into your Docker
Hub account you should end up at a page
that looks like this and from here you
just want to click this repositories Tab
and what we're going to do is we're
going to create the repositories that
we're going to push our container images
to and then our kubernetes configuration
is going to pull from this repository
the repositories that we create for each
individual service now your repositories
are going to have the same suffix as
mine because we're going to create the
repository name using the same suffix
but the prefix to your repository is
going to be different mine's going to
have this prefix and yours is going to
be whatever the name of your account is
so for example if we create a repository
here
and we name the repository auth because
it's going to be the repository for our
auth services images when we actually
push to this repository from our command
line I'm going to push to sweezytech
auth and you're going to push to
whatever your username is for your
account and you'll see what I mean by
that in a second so we're going to go
ahead and create this repository for our
auth services images and we're just
going to make it public because we only
can make one private one and then if we
do a private one we're going to have to
configure credentials within minicube
which is a little bit more complicated
so we're just going to do public and
throughout this tutorial it will be
possible for you to push and pull from
my repository which can cause lots of
issues for you as you follow along with
this tutorial because my images may or
may not be in the same state that they
are at the part of the tutorial that
you're on so just make sure you take the
time to create this account and create
your own repositories so we can just go
ahead and create this and now as you can
see here it tells you how to push to
this repository and as you can see this
is going to look different for you than
it does for me specifically this part is
going to look different for you
so anyways now what we want to do is we
want to tag the image that we just
created here we just built an image
using this Docker builds command it
built the image based on our Docker file
that we just created now we want to tag
this image so we'll do Docker tag and
we're going to just use this Shaw here
you don't actually need to put in the
whole thing but I'm just going to put in
the whole thing and you're just going to
tag it using your username from your
Docker Hub account
slash auth and then we're going to tag
it as latest because it's going to be
the most recent version of our image
now if we do Docker image LS you can see
that we have our tag here and you can
compare this part of the image ID to the
first part of this shot and just ignore
all of these other images that I have
you'll likely have whatever images you
have on your system as well but none of
that matters as long as you have this
image tag here then you're fine so let's
just go ahead and clear that and now
that we've tagged it we can push it to
our repository so we'll just do Docker
push and again you're just going to use
your username for your Docker Hub
account and then auth and then latest
and then just push that
and once that's finished you can go to
the repository and you can just refresh
the page
and you should see your image tag here
so that means we've successfully pushed
this image to our repository and now
whenever we want to pull this image we
could just do Docker pool and we could
just do
the name of our image and the tag or the
URL for our image in the tag
and we'd be able to pull it but that's
not actually how we're going to be
pulling these images our kubernetes
configuration is actually going to be
pulling the images so let's go ahead and
clear
and now we're going to make a directory
called Manifest this directory is going
to contain all of our kubernetes
configurations so let's change directory
to manifest
and for all of these configuration files
I'm going to go over them in detail
after we write them out so if you're
confused about the infrastructure code
that we're writing just hang in there so
all of our configuration files are going
to be yaml files and we'll start with a
file called off deploy.yaml and within
this file we'll do API version apps V1
foreign
is deployment now again this is the
configuration for our kubernetes cluster
and our service and if you're not
familiar with kubernetes a lot of these
configurations you probably won't
understand I will try to go into more
detail for these in a little bit so
we'll do metadata name of our service or
our deployment is going to be off
and labels
app is going to be auth as well
and then we're going to do our spec
in replicas we're going to want two
replicas or two instances of our service
and selector we're going to match labels
and the app will be off
strategy
type
rolling update and the configuration for
Rolling update
we're going to do Max surge equals three
then we want to do template
metadata for template labels
app off
and we'll do spec again
containers
name auth and this is where we're going
to configure it to pool our image we're
going to set image to
remember this should be your username
and then auth
and then ports
the container port
is going to be 5000 because our
application is running on Port 5000 so
we'll just do the same for container
Port as well and then we want to get our
environment variables from config map
file we're going to create this file
after this so we're going to do config
map ref and we're going to name the
config map that we're going to create
auth config map and again we haven't
created this yet we're going to create
it soon and here we're going to do
Secret ref and we're going to store our
secrets in a secret we're going to name
it auth secret
and we're going to create this file as
well
and let's just check formatting and
looks fine
so we can just go ahead and save that so
now let's create the config map so we'll
just do Vim
configmap.yaml this config map is going
to set environment variables within our
container so for this one we'll do API
version
B1 kind config map
metadata name is going to be auth config
map and data are going to be our
environment variables so we'll do MySQL
post and since we're going to be using
our local MySQL server we're going to
need to reference that server from
within our kubernetes cluster and
luckily minicube gives us a way to
access our host the Clusters hosts via
this host dot miniq dot internal because
basically within the cluster we're kind
of in our own isolated Network so since
our MySQL server is just deployed to our
local host from within the cluster we
wouldn't be able to just use localhost
we need to access the system that's
hosting the cluster and that's what this
host mini Cube internal is for
so our MySQL user is going to be off
user we created and our MySQL DB
is going to be auth which we also
created and default port for MySQL is
3306 and actually we should do it as a
string so these are going to be the
environment variables that will
automatically be exported within our
Shale when we do the deployment so in
other words if we were to run the
environment command within that
container all of these variables and
their values are going to be present
within the container
so that's what this config map file is
for and configmap is for environment
variables that aren't necessarily
sensitive data like passwords so we're
also going to need to do a similar file
for our secrets or sensitive data like
our password to our database and of
course in a production environment you
would never push your secrets
configuration to like a git repository
or something because then your passwords
would be easily visible at the
repository so just keep that in mind
when we're creating this file so we're
just going to call it secret.yaml
and API version once again V1 and this
time kind is going to be secret and
metadata we're going to do name auth
Secret
and we're going to do string data
and we'll do MySQL password is going to
be auth123 and our JWT secret is another
secret that we need for this application
and we're just going to make it a random
name sarcasm
and we need to set type to opaque
and this is going to be our environment
variables for our secrets and we can
just go ahead and check if the
formatting is okay and save that and
lastly we need to create our
service.yaml and we'll do API version
V1 and kind is going to be service
metadata will be name is auth that's
going to be the name of the overall
service and spec
we'll do selector
app off and we'll do type
cluster IP and this cluster IP basically
just means that the IP address assigned
to this service is only going to be
accessible within our cluster but again
I'll go into a little bit more details
soon
and our Port is going to be 5000
our Target Port 5000 as well
and protocol is going to be TCP
and then we can just save that so once
we have all of our info code for our
kubernetes deployment we can actually
start to deploy this off service to our
cluster
so let's go ahead and take a look at
canines So currently we have nothing in
canines there's no cluster and there's
no context because our mini Cube isn't
running right now
so we can actually do
any Cube start
and once mini cube is started we should
be able to go back into canines
and if we change the namespace to All by
hitting zero
here
we can see
that we have our mini Cube pods running
within the cube system namespace
and you can see here our cluster is mini
Cube so let's go ahead and Ctrl C out of
there and we can clear this
okay so let me just briefly go over what
we're doing here so basically within
this manifest directory we wrote the
infrastructure code for our auth
deployment so if we change directory
back to our main directory we wrote the
code for our auth service and we created
a Docker file to build that source code
into a Docker image and we then pushed
that Docker image to a repository on the
internet and within our manifest
infrastructure code
we're actually pulling that image from
the internet and deploying it to
kubernetes and that image contains our
code
so all of these files within this
manifest directory when applied will
interface with the kubernetes API which
is the API for our kubernetes cluster to
interface with our kubernetes cluster so
these files are going to interface with
that API to create our service and its
corresponding resources like its config
map and its secret and to do that all we
need to do is do Cube CTL
apply and then we're going to use this F
flag for file and we're just going to
apply all the files in the current
directory this manifest directory
and as you can see here our config map
resource was created and our secret was
created and our service was created but
we actually had an error here for our
deployment so it's saying that let's see
a known field template
so this seems like there's an issue with
our auth deploy.yaml file let's go ahead
and have a look
so a template shouldn't be unknown
so the spacing is really important in
yaml files so we'll put this back one
because strategy is actually part of
spec
but the way we had it before
we had strategy a part of selector
so we need to make sure that spacing is
correct in these files
so we'll go ahead and
put this back
and let's give it a try now
so we can just apply again and it will
only apply the files that have changed
and now we're getting unknown field name
so I'm assuming that it's an issue with
the spacing again so let's just go over
this
so the issue here is that our config map
reference the name shouldn't be at the
same spacing it should be
there and the same for the secret ref
name
so we can go ahead and save and let's
try to apply again and now we were able
to create our deployment as well so now
that we've created these resources we
can go into K9s
and we can see that we have two
instances of our auth service being
created
and now both instances are running and
if we go into the logs by just pressing
enter on first the Pod and then the
container we can see the logs within the
container and we see that our server is
running
and that's for both of these replicas
and also within canines we can use the
shell within the container by just
entering on the Pod and then pressing s
on the container to access the shell
so now we're in a shell within our
container and within this shell we can
do environment and we can see our
environment variables so you can see we
have our secret here our MySQL password
and we have our MySQL user here actually
we can just environment grep MySQL and
we can see all of our MySQL environment
variables from both our config map and
our secret
and we can just exit the shell here and
leave canines okay so to explain our
kubernetes configuration I will need to
explain a little bit more about
kubernetes in general so throughout this
course there's been a lot of mention of
deploying our micro services to a
kubernetes cluster but what does that
actually mean let's first briefly go
over what kubernetes is in simple terms
kubernetes eliminates many of the manual
processes involved in deploying and
scaling containerized applications for
example if we configure a service to
have four pods kubernetes will keep
track of how many pods are up and
running and if any of the pods go down
for any reason kubernetes will
automatically scale the deployment so
that the number of PODS matches the
configured amount so there's no need to
manually deploy individual pods when a
pod crashes kubernetes also makes
manually scaling pods more streamlined
for example say I have a service that
load balances requests to individual
pods using round robin and that service
is experiencing more traffic than the
number of available pods can handle as a
result of this I decide to scale my
service up from two to five pods without
kubernetes in a situation like this I'd
likely need to go manually deploy each
individual additional pod and then I'd
need to reconfigure the load balancer to
include the new pods in the round robin
algorithm but kubernetes can handle all
of this for you and it's as simple as
running this command with this simple
command kubernetes will scale up your
service which includes maintaining the
newly scaled number of PODS if a pod
happens to crash and it will auto
configure the load balancer to include
the new pods basically with kubernetes
weekend cluster together a bunch of
containerized services and easily
orchestrate the deployment and
management of these services within the
cluster using what we call kubernetes
Objects which are persisted did entities
in the kubernetes system I know that
sounds a bit complicated so let me
explain so for this part of the
explanation let's go to the kubernetes
documentation
so it's explained here that a kubernetes
object is a record of intent once you
create the object the kubernetes system
will constantly work to ensure that
object exists by creating an object
you're effectively telling the
kubernetes system what you want your
cluster's workload to look like this is
your cluster's desired State now this
sounds complicated but we've actually
already done this multiple times for
example we created a deployment object
here in this yaml file this file is the
above mentioned record of intent we are
telling kubernetes that we want this
deployment object to exist in our
cluster in the state specified in our
spec here for example we want two
replicas to be deployed once this
configuration is applied as explained
here the kubernetes control plane
continually and actively manages every
object's actual state to match the
desired State you supplied that means
that kubernetes will keep track of the
actual status or state of your
deployment and make sure that it matches
your record of intent in other words
your yaml specification
so bringing it all together we can say
that our kubernetes cluster is comprised
of a bunch of objects that we've
configured that describe our cluster's
intended state from there kubernetes
will continually compare the current
status or state of those objects to the
specification or desired state from our
original configuration and if that
comparison ever differs kubernetes will
automatically make adjustments to match
the current status with our original
record of intent in other words our
original specification so how do we
communicate with kubernetes to configure
and or create these objects well let's
once again take a look at the
documentation it's explained here that
to work with kubernetes objects whether
to create modify or delete them you will
need to use the kubernetes API when you
use the cube CTL command line interface
for example the CLI makes the necessary
kubernetes API calls for you so
basically the Q CTL CLI that we
installed is interfacing with the
kubernetes API to essentially run crud
operations on our clusters objects in
our case we are running our cluster
locally using mini Cube so the end point
for the kubernetes API in this case is
on our local machine but in the real
world your cluster will usually be
deployed on some server and on your
local machine you'll have a kubernetes
configuration for the cluster on that
server which will enable your local Cube
CTL CLI to interface with the remote
server but we don't need to go into the
details for that in this video so now
that we have a general understanding of
what kubernetes is and how it is working
we can now get into explaining our
actual yaml configuration files so if we
have a look at the documentation here we
see that there are some required fields
necessary when creating kubernetes
objects using the dot yaml files those
are API version kind metadata and spec
we can also see a description for each
field API version is which version of
the kubernetes API we are using to
create this object kind is what kind of
object we want to create for example
deployment config map secret
Etc metadata is just data that helps
uniquely identify the object and lastly
spec is the desired state or record of
intent for the object which we explained
before as mentioned here spec format is
different for every kubernetes object
type for example the spec format for an
object of kind deployment will be
different from the spec format for an
object of kind service and to see how to
configure the spec for specific types of
objects we can use the kubernetes API
reference
so let's go over the spec format for our
deployment object configuration so first
as you can see here we have all of the
required fields we have API version
which is the required field here we have
kind which is the required field here
and we have metadata which is the
required field here and as mentioned in
this dock the precise format of the
object spec is different for every
kubernetes object so anything within
this spec block is our deployment spec
so to see the actual format for the spec
for a deployment we can just go to the
kubernetes API reference here
and a deployment is a workload resource
so we would click this workload resource
and we see we have deployment here so we
can select deployment
so this here is basically giving us the
overall configuration for a deployment
so it's showing the API version and the
kind and the metadata as well and it
also tells us the object metadata
because as you can see here our metadata
has its own nested fields
so if we were to hit that object
metadata we'd get a description for each
field that we have within our metadata
so name and it tells us that name must
be unique within the namespace and that
it's required when creating a resource
and if we scroll down here we see that
we have additional fields that we're not
using currently but that we can use
within our metadata block
and then we have labels which we're
using here and it tells us the format
for the labels is it's a map of string
keys and string values so for example
this app would be the key and auth would
be the value for our labels
so let's go back and get into the spec
configuration so as you can see here is
spec and then there's a deployment spec
link that we can select that will give
us the details of the actual spec format
for a deployment so we have our spec
here and any of the fields nested within
this spec block are going to be present
here so we can get a detailed
explanation of each individual field so
for example the selector here is the
selector that we have here and if we
click label selector
we can find this matched labels that
we're using here down here
and basically what match labels is doing
it says here a label selector is a label
query over a set of resources and to
understand what I mean by that let's go
back to what a selector is here so as
you can see here it says label selector
for pods existing replica sets whose
pods are selected by this will be the
ones affected by this deployment and it
must match the Pod templates labels so
as you can see within our template which
we're going to get to for our replicas
we're setting the label with key app and
value auth so we're going to get into it
but this template is basically going to
be the configuration for each individual
pod and our deployment is basically
going to know what pods are part of the
overall deployment because this selector
is going to match the labels that are
assigned to each individual pod in our
template here
so simply put our deployment knows what
pods are part of the deployment because
based on this template each pod is going
to be deployed with a label that's a key
value pair where the key is going to be
app and the value is going to be auth
and our deployment is going to select
pods using the same label app off as the
key and value
and then we can go here to replicas and
as you can see here replicas is the
number of desired pods and you already
saw how this replicas is working you saw
that when we actually applied our
configuration there were two auth pods
deployed so if we were to increase this
to say four then four auth pods would be
deployed when we apply the configuration
and then we can head over here to
strategy which is here and this is just
the deployment strategy to use to
replace existing pods with new ones and
basically this is the difference between
here killing all of the existing pods
before creating new ones which would
essentially mean that our service is
unavailable during the creation of new
pods or replacing our old replica sets
by new ones using rolling update which
basically gradually scales down the old
replica sets and scales up new ones and
in our case we're actually configuring
the max surge here to three which is
this here and this is the maximum number
of PODS that can be scheduled above the
desired number of PODS so for example if
our desired number of PODS is two and we
need to do an update a rolling update it
might be necessary to exceed the number
of replicas while some pods are shutting
down and newer pods are spinning up so
this Max surge is just to give us some
extra Headroom when we're actually
needing to update our deployment and
lastly we get into our template here
and simply put template describes the
pods that will be created we've already
gone over this a little bit but let's
actually go into the Pod template spec
so everything nested under this template
field is within the Pod template spec so
we have here our metadata and metadata
is the same for all of the types so
object metadata is going to be the same
regardless of the type
so if we click this we see that it's
still just name and all of the other
fields that are possible within metadata
and same thing with spec but this time
the spec here isn't the same spec as
deployment because remember each type
has its own spec format so this spec is
going to be pod spec here so if we
select pod spec
we get a different set of fields and
descriptions for a spec for a template
which is a pod spec because the template
is the template for pods so as you can
see here we have containers then we have
containers here as well
and this is where we Define our
container so we need to name the
container and we need to set an image
for our container as well and remember
we're pulling our image for our
container from our Docker repository and
that's the image that's going to be used
for our container within our pod so
that's image here and then we have ports
which we can find here and this ports is
actually similar to the expose
instruction that we did in our Docker
file doesn't actually serve as anything
other than documentation so as you can
see here it says list of ports to expose
from the container exposing a port here
gives the system additional information
about the network connection a container
uses but is primarily informational so
not specifying a port here does not
prevent that Port from being exposed so
any port which is listening on the
default
0.0.0.0 address inside a container will
be accessible from the network so we've
already gone over all of this when we
were configuring our Docker file so you
should be familiar so yeah this
container Port 5000 is similar to our
expose instruction in our Docker file it
serves as documentation essentially and
let's see if we can just search for
environment from
foreign
so we have environment from here which
is this configuration here and it's just
list of resources to populate
environment variables in the container
so as I explained to you and showed to
you our config map is where we Define
our environment variables for our
container which you were able to see
when we went into the shell for our
container so we're using an additional
resource config map
which can be seen here and it's the
config map to select from for the
environment variables for the container
and down here we also have our secret
ref or this one for that matter the
contents of the target secret data field
will represent the key value pairs as
environment variables so essentially the
secrets are being stored as environment
variables as well and the secrets come
from our secrets configuration and both
this config map and the secret are their
own individual kubernetes objects as
well so basically whenever you see kind
and a name that means that's an
individual kubernetes object so as you
can see for our configuration file for
our config map it has its own kind and
config map type so this is going to
create another object in our kubernetes
cluster and as you can see each object
configuration is going to have
essentially similar Fields overall like
they're all going to need an API version
a kind metadata but some things might
differ like this here is a data field
which we don't use in our actual
deployment object configuration and
here's another example when we created
Our Kind service we still have the
metadata field with its nested field
name and again we have the spec for the
kind service but of course this spec
format is going to be specific to the
kind service so it'll be different from
our deployment spec format and this API
reference documentation is very
important and I will have a link to it
in the description of this video so now
we can start to write the code for our
Gateway service so we can just change
directory
back to our python Source directory and
right now we only have our auth service
but we can also make their Gateway
and we'll go ahead and change directory
into Gateway and to start we want to
create a virtual environment as usual
and then we want to start our virtual
environment
and as you can see our virtual
environment variable is the Gateway
virtual environment now the next thing
that we want to do is create a file
called server.pi so our Gateway service
is going to have a few dependencies so
we're going to need to import
and actually let me go ahead and install
some Vim dependencies
so we're going to need to import OS
we're going to need to import grid FS
pica
and Json and we're also going to need to
import flask
and request and we're going to need to
import flask Pi [ __ ]
and we're going to create an auth
package
and we're going to create a validate
module within that package and we're
also going to create an auth service
package and we're going to import module
access from that package
and we're also going to need to create a
storage package and we'll import util
from the storage package
so these we haven't created yet but
we're going to create soon
and flask by [ __ ] we're going to use
mongodb to store our files
and this grid FS is basically going to
allow us to store larger files in
mongodb and I'll explain a little bit
more about that when we get to it and
this Pika here is going to be what we
use to interface with our queue we're
going to be using a rabbitmq service to
store our messages and I'll go over that
more once we get to it as well
so to start we just want to create our
server so server is going to be equal to
flask
so in our server config
we can do [ __ ]
URI
and set it equal to
mongodb at
host.minicube dot internal
at Port
27017 which is the default mongodb port
and at database that we're going to call
videos so if you remember this host mini
Cube internal just gives us access to
our local host from within our
kubernetes cluster and this is just a
mongodb URI that's going to be the
endpoint to interface with our mongodb
so our config is going to have the
configuration to our mongodb that's on
the Local Host that we haven't yet
installed but we will
then we're just going to create a
variable called [ __ ] and we're going to
do PI [ __ ]
server
and I will explain what this is doing in
a second but first let's just go ahead
and install all of our dependencies
so we can go ahead and save this and
we'll just cat server.pi so we can see
what we need to install and we'll do
pip3 install
pika
and pip3 install flask
and let's cut that again so we can see
pip3 install I believe it's high [ __ ]
and once we've installed those
dependencies we can go back in here
foreign
[Music]
flask Pi [ __ ]
which is flask
hi [ __ ]
and now let's go back in here and see
and we have a type over here this should
be a small l
so now here what this line of code is
doing
so what we need to know about this line
of code is that this Pi [ __ ] is going
to wrap our flask server which is going
to allow us to interface with our
mongodb so if we go to the definition
here we see that it manages mongodb
connections for our flask app
so this essentially is abstracting the
handling of the mongodb connections away
from us so beyond that we don't really
need to understand what's actually
happening for the purposes of our use
case
and once we've created that [ __ ]
variable or the pi [ __ ] instance we're
going to create FS for grid fs and we're
going to create an instance of this grid
FS class and we need to pass in our DB
from our [ __ ] database
which is going to be this video's DB
so grid FS is going to wrap our mongodb
which is going to enable us to use
mongodb's grid FS so let me quickly
explain what grid FS is okay so we're
going to very quickly go over what grid
FS is in relation to our mongodb so
we're using mongodb to store our files
files being both our MP3 files and our
video files and if we go to mongodb's
limits and thresholds documentation we
can see that a binary Json document size
has a maximum size of 16 megabytes and
it's explained here that the maximum
document size helps ensure that a single
document cannot use an excessive amount
of Ram or during transmission excessive
amounts of bandwidth so they're
basically saying that handling files
over 16 megabytes in memory will result
in Prof performance degradation so what
they provide as an alternative is grid
FS which essentially allows us to work
with files larger than 16 megabytes by
sharding the files for example if we go
to the gridfs documentation here we see
that grid FS is a specification for
storing and retrieving files that exceed
the binary Json document size limit of
16 megabytes and it says instead of
storing a file in a single document
gridfs divides files into parts or
chunks and it stores each chunk as a
separate document so in this case we'd
no longer be dealing with files larger
than 16 megabytes in memory because a
file larger than that size would be
separated into chunks and we're only
dealing with the individual chunks at
that point which avoids the performance
degradation issue so when using grid FS
gridfs uses two collections to store
files and you can just think of
collections in mongodb as tables so it's
explained here that one of those
collections stores the file chunks and
then there's another collection that
stores the files metadata so this
collection that stores the file's
metadata basically contains the
information necessary to reassemble the
chunks to create or reform the original
file and if you're interested in more
details about this gridfs or mongodb for
that matter has very good documentation
so you can come and read additionally
about this but you'll see later on in
the tutorial these are the two
collections that we'll be working with
to work with these files and the reason
we're actually using gridfs is because
working with video files there's a high
probability that will eventually be
working with files larger than 16
megabytes so this is essentially going
to Future proof our application but for
the purposes of this tutorial you don't
really need to know much beyond what I
just explained but again if you're the
type of person that likes to dive deeper
into these types of details like me then
I recommend reading this page as well
which is actually pretty interesting now
the next thing that we're going to want
to do is configure our rabbitmq
connection
so we'll just create a variable called
connection and we're going to use Pica
dot blocking connection
which is essentially going to make our
communication with our rapidm QQ
synchronous and again the details of how
this is working are abstracted away from
us so we don't need to worry too much
about that so in here we're going to add
our connection parameters
and we're going to pass to our
connection parameters the host for our
rapidm QQ and we're going to deploy our
queue as a stateful set in our
kubernetes cluster and it's going to be
accessible via just the name rabbitmq
and we haven't configured this yet we're
going to configure it later but just
know that this rabbit mq string is
referencing our rabbitmq host and once
we create this instance of a blocking
connection we want to create a channel
with just the connection that we just
created dot Channel
so let's briefly go over how rabbitmq is
going to integrate with our overall
architecture so we already know how the
off flow works so we don't need to go
over that again but now let's go over
how rabbitmq integrates with our overall
architecture so when a user uploads a
video to be converted to MP3 that
request will first hit our Gateway our
Gateway will then store the video in
mongodb and then put a message on this
queue here which is our rapid in Q
letting Downstream Services know that
there is a video to be processed in
mongodb the video to MP3 converter
service will consume messages from the
queue it will then get the ID of the
video from the message pull that video
from mongodb convert the video to MP3
then store the MP3 on mongodb then put a
new message on the Queue to be consumed
by the notification service that says
that the conversion job is done the
notification service this consumes those
messages from the queue and sends an
email notification to the client
informing the client that the MP3 for
the video that he or she uploaded is
ready for download the client will then
use a unique ID acquired from the
notification plus his or her JWT to make
a request to the API Gateway to download
the MP3 and the API Gateway will pull
the MP3 from mongodb and serve it to the
client and that is the overall
conversion flow and how rapidmq is
integrated with the overall system okay
so now that we have a clear
understanding of the overall flow of our
system we can now use that understanding
to familiarize ourself with some key
terms when considering microservice
architectures those terms are
asynchronous and synchronous
inter-service communication and strong
and eventual consistency let's start
with synchronous inter-service
communication because understanding that
will make it easy easier to understand
everything else so synchronous
inter-service communication put simply
means that the client service sending
the request awaits the response from the
service that it is sending the request
to the client service can't do anything
while it waits for this response so it
is essentially blocked so this request
is considered a blocking request for
example our Gateway service communicates
with our auth service synchronously so
when the Gateway service sends an HTTP
post request to our auth service to log
in a user and retrieve a JWT for that
user our Gateway service is blocked
until the auth service either Returns
the JWT or an error so communication
between our API Gateway and our off
service is synchronous which makes those
two Services tightly coupled now on the
other end of the spectrum we have
asynchronous inter-service communication
so with asynchronous inter-service
communication the client service does
not need to await the response of the
downstream service therefore this is
considered a non-blocking request this
is achieved in our case by using a cue
for example in our architecture our
Gateway service needs to communicate
with our converter service but if our
Gateway were to communicate with our
converter service in a synchronous
manner the performance of our Gateway
would take a hit because if the Gateway
were to get many requests to convert
large videos the processes that make
requests to the converter service would
be blocked until the converter service
finishes processing the videos so let's
say that hypothetically our Gateway
service processes one request per thread
concurrently or at the same time if we
have two processes with four threads
each that's eight concurrent requests if
our Gateway were to get more than eight
requests to process large videos the
entirety of our gateways threads would
be blocked awaiting the completion of
the processing of each request so in
this case synchronous communication
between our Gateway and our converter
service would not be scalable and this
is where our queue comes into the
picture as explained before our Gateway
doesn't communicate directly with our
converter service therefore it does not
depend on the converter Services
response this means that in our current
architecture our Gateway and our
converter service are Loosely coupled
this decoupling is done by using the
queue our Gateway just stores the video
on mongodb and throws a message on the
queue for a downstream service to
process the video at its convenience so
in this case the only thing holding up
the threads on our Gateway service is
the uploading of the video to mongodb
and putting the message on the Queue
which means that our Gateway Services
threads will be freed up much quicker
allowing for our gateway to handle more
incoming requests so with the current
architecture our Gateway service is
asynchronously communicating with our
converter service that is it sends
requests to the converter service in the
form of messages on the Queue but it
doesn't need to wait for nor does it
care about a response from the converter
service it essentially just sends and
forgets the message and this same thing
is happening with the communication
between the converter service and the
notification service now let's get into
strong consistency versus eventual
consistency let's start with an example
of what our application flow would look
like if it were strongly consistent so
let's say that hypothetically whenever a
user uploads a video to our gateway to
be converted to an MP3 we make a
synchronous request to our converter
service waiting for the conversion to
complete and then in response the
converter sends an ID for the MP3 back
to the user once the conversion is
complete at the point that the user
received that ID it's certain that the
video has been processed and converted
into an MP3 and that the data is
consistent with the update so at that
point if the user were to request to
download the data based on that ID the
user is guaranteed to get the most
recent update of that data so that is
strong consistency eventual consistency
on the other hand is a bit different so
let's use our actual architecture as an
example in this case for the sake of
example let's say that hypothetically
when our Gateway uploads the video to
mongodb and puts the message on the
queue for it to be processed we return a
download ID to the user at that moment I
know that we don't return a download ID
to the user at that moment in our actual
application this is just to help you to
understand if the user were to upload a
video that takes one minute to process
but immediately after receiving the ID
the user tried to download the MP3 the
MP3 would not yet be available because
it would still be processing in that
case but the MP3 eventually will be
available so if the user were to wait
one minute and then request to download
the MP3 with that same ID at that point
the MP3 would be available therefore the
data is eventually consistent and that
is eventual consistency
okay so the first route that we're going
to make for our Gateway is going to be
our login route
and we're going to define a function
called login
and what this route is going to do is
it's going to communicate with our auth
service to log the user in and assign a
token to that user so we'll set token
error equal to
access Dot Login
and we're going to pass in the request
and this request is from flask and we're
importing it here
and we're going to create a module
called access that's going to contain
this login function so let's just go
ahead and save this and let's clear and
in our Gateway directory we want to
create another directory that we'll call
auth service
and we'll CD into that directory and
we'll create a file called init.pi which
is essentially going to mark this
directory as a package
and we'll also create a file called
access.pi which is going to be the
module that contains our login function
and we're going to need to import OS and
we also need to import requests and this
request is different from the request
that we import from flask this request
is going to be the module that we use to
make HTTP calls to our auth service
so we can go ahead and Define log in and
we take in request which is not to be
confused with this requests
and we're going to set auth equal to
request Dot
authorization and as we write the code
for this just pay close attention to
requests versus requests with an S at
the end because they're different so
this request object has this
authorization attribute so if when we
create this variable this variable
resolves To None So if not auth that
means that there's no authorization
parameters in our request so that means
that we need to return none for our
token and we need to return for our
error missing credentials
and a 401
so if we go ahead and save this
and quit and go back into our
server.pi file
we see that we're setting token and
error equal to
access.login so access.login needs to
return a tuple and the first item in the
Tuple will go to token and the second
item in the Tuple will go to error so if
we go back to the definition in this
case when we're missing credentials
we're going to return none for the token
and we're going to return an error but
upon the successful login of a user
we're going to return none for the error
and we're going to return an actual
token
so we'll set basic auth equal to
auth.username and auth.password
and we've already gone over basic auth
so you should already be familiar with
this
and we're going to set our response
equal to
requests dot post
now this request is going to be the
request that's going to make the HTTP
call to our auth service so let's save
this actually and we need to install
requests
and let's go back into our access file
so this request.post is going to make a
post request to our auth service and the
parameters or the arguments that we need
to pass are the string the URL endpoint
string and our auth header and the way
that we do that is we can just create a
formatted string
and we'll do OS Dot environ.get
and we'll just get our auth service
address which we're going to create so
we're going to create this off service
address environment variable which is
going to be the address for our auth
service and we're going to need to
access the login endpoint
and to create the basic auth header
we're just going to do auth equals basic
auth
and once this request completes this
response is going to contain the result
and we're going to check if response dot
status code
equals 200
that means that we're good we're going
to return response dot text which is
going to be our token and none for the
error otherwise
we'll return none if we don't get a 200
response it means we didn't get our
token so we'll return none and we'll
just return response.txt
and response dot status code
and we can go ahead and save that
and this should be
double equal
and let's format
and this is spelled wrong
and we can save this file and let's just
clear this
let's just change directory back to our
main directory and go back into
server.pi
so once we call this access.login we're
going to check if not error and that's
because if there is an error this is
going to contain an error but if there
is no error this is going to be null or
none and if that's the case we can just
return our token
otherwise if there is an error then
we're just going to return the error
and that's going to be it for our login
function
now the next route that we want to
create is our upload route and this is
going to be the route that we use to
upload our video that we want to convert
into an MP3
so we're just going to call it upload
and methods will be just post
so we'll Define a function called upload
and now for this route we need to make
sure that the user has a token from our
login route so we need to validate our
user so we're going to set access and
error equal to validate dot token
and we're going to create this validate
module as well and we're going to pass
in the request so let's go ahead and
create this validate module with this
token function
so we'll go ahead and save and let's
clear and we'll make dur and this dirt
will just call auth the other one we
call it auth service because we're
communicating with the auth service on
behalf of the user or the client but
auth is going to just be used internally
so our Gateway is going to use this auth
package to validate tokens that it
receives from the client so we'll make
their auth
and let's change their auth and once
again we need to create this init.pi
file to mark this directory as a package
and we'll create a file called
validate.pi and we will import OS and
requests once again
and we'll Define a function called token
which takes in a request because we're
validating a token
so remember the flow is the client's
going to access our internal services or
our endpoints by first logging in and
getting a JWT and then for all
subsequent requests the client is going
to have an authorization header
containing that JWT which tells our API
Gateway that that client has access to
the endpoints of our overall application
so this validate token function that
we're creating here is going to be the
function that validates that JWT sent by
the client so we need to first check to
see if the client has the authorization
header in his request or his or her
request
foreign
is not in request.headers we're going to
return none for our access and we're
going to return an error that says
missing credentials
and it's going to be a 401. otherwise
we're going to set our token equal to
request dot headers
authorization
and if that token does not exist we'll
return none as well and the same error
missing credentials
401
but if the token does exist and the
authorization header exists we'll set
response equal to request dot post
and this should be requests so don't
make the same mistake I did and once
again we're going to send a post request
via HTTP to our auth service so once
again we'll do a formatted string
and we're going to get our host from the
environment
using the environment variable auth
service address
and we're going to access the validate
endpoint
and headers will be equal to
authorization
token
so we're basically just passing along
the authorization token to our validate
request of our auth service
and we want to check the response if
response dot status code
equals 200 then we're good so that means
we're going to return
response.txt and none and response.text
is going to contain the body which will
be the axis that the bearer of this
token has and you'll see what I mean by
that when we parse this
else if the response from our auth
service isn't 200 we're going to return
none and we're going to return an error
so response Dot txt and response dot
status code
and we can save that and let's go back
to our root directory and back into our
server.pi file okay so let's take a
second to understand what's happening
here with our validation before moving
forward so let's quickly go back into
our auth service and into the server.pi
file
and let's go over our login route so if
you remember our login route here is
going to take a username and a password
or an email and a password and return a
token and the token is going to be a
Json web token and that token is being
created here in this create JWT function
and as you can see in this function
we're encoding a payload and that
payload is here and this payload
contains our claims which is basically
these data points within the payload so
our username is a claim the expiration
date is a claim and also contained
within this payload is this claim here
for admin which is just a bull that's
going to be true or false and as I said
earlier we're just going to allow
anybody with admin equal to True access
to all of the endpoints of our services
so the token that's returned to the
logged in client is going to contain
this payload but the payload is going to
be encrypted
and when that client sends their token
in their request and we validate it in
using the validate endpoint for our off
service we're going to first check to
see if the token exists in the request
and then we're going to decode that
token and when we're decoding the token
we're using the same key that we signed
the token with this JWT secret which is
how we know that this is a valid token
because our auth service is the service
that signed the token using this key and
when we decode the token we're using the
same key the service is key so if
somebody were to send a token that was
signed with a different secret key then
of course it wouldn't work and when we
decode this token with this decoded
variable is going to include that
payload that tells us who the user is
via their username which is their email
and their privileges which is the auth's
claim which is true or false so now
let's go back into our Gateway code code
and here when a user tries to upload
they need to have a token header which
we're going to validate using our
function to validate the token and the
Gateway is just going to forward this
token to our auth services validate
endpoint and the response that we expect
from our auth service is that decoded
body
so here when we get a successful
response a 200 response what we're
returning here in this response.txt is
going to be the body of that token
containing the claims so it's
essentially it's going to be the decoded
token where the body is visible and it's
going to be a string which is going to
be Json formatted
and that means that here this access
variable is going to resolve to that
Json string that contains our payload
with our claims so here we'll set access
equal to Json dot loads
access
and if we go to the definition of this
you see that it deserializes an instance
containing a Json document to a python
object so we're essentially just
converting this Json string to a python
object so that we can work with it in
code
and what's being converted into a python
object is this here
so our python object is going to look
like this once we've decoded the Json
so let's just go back
and we can go ahead and close this
so this access is going to contain that
object and that object has the admin
claim which is going to be a bull which
is true or false and actually just to be
clear let me show what I mean by that
so this admin claim here is going to
contain the auths which is a wool which
is true or false and if it's true we'll
give the user access to all of the
endpoints
so we're going to check for that claim
so we're going to say if access which is
the object that was converted from the
Json so we're going to say if access
admin which is essentially saying if the
admin claim resolves to true then we're
going to give the user access
so let's go ahead and close that again
so if the user does have access we're
going to make sure that there's a file
to be uploaded in the first place
so if there's a file being uploaded the
request should contain a dictionary in
this request.files so we're going to say
if the length of request.files is
greater than one because we're only
going to allow the uploading of one file
at a time for now
or the length of request.files is less
than one because we want there to be
exactly one file so we don't want more
than one file then we don't want less
than one file so if one of these is true
then we're going to return
exactly one file required
and a 400.
and this
request.files dictionary is going to
have a key for the file which will be
defined when we send the request and the
actual file as the value
so that means that
we should iterate through the key values
in the request.files dictionary so we'll
do for key which we don't need to use
and file which is the value in
request.files.items
for every file we're going to upload it
where we're going to do an upload and
there should only be one file so this
should only happen once
so we'll do util dot upload and we
haven't created this function yet but we
will and this function is going to take
us parameters to file our grid FS
instance our rabbitmq Channel and the
axis which was just explained above and
this function is going to return an
error if something goes wrong but if
nothing goes wrong then it won't return
anything it'll return none
so to check if something went wrong
we're just going to check if error and
if there is an error we're just going to
return error
and after this for Loop completes if
we've never returned an error then that
means it was successful so we'll just
return
success
with a 200 and that's what's going to be
happening if the user is authorized but
if the user isn't authorized so we need
to go down here and do else
so this is the block that's going to get
executed if the user isn't authorized
and in that case we're just going to
return not
authorized
and a 401
and that's going to be our upload route
and remember we still need to go and
create this upload function but I'm
going to get to that in a second because
that function is going to be a little
bit involved
so before we do that let's just finish
up our template here for our Gateway
server so we'll do the final endpoint
which is going to be server.route
and this is going to be the download
endpoint which is the endpoint that is
going to be used to download the MP3
that was created from the video and this
is going to be methods and we're only
going to do git and we're going to
Define download
and for now we'll just pass this is just
a template portion for this function or
this endpoint and lastly we need to set
if name
equals
Main
we're going to run our server and again
we're going to set our host to 0.0.0.0
and our port in this case is going to be
880.
and this is going to be our Gateway
service template including both the
login endpoint and the upload endpoint
and to be continued on the download
endpoint so let's go ahead and save this
and actually let's go back in here so I
don't confuse you
so now what we're going to need to
create is this upload function here and
this util as you can see is coming from
this here so from Storage import util so
we need to create a storage package and
within that package we need to create a
util module
so we'll make their storage
change there into storage and we'll
create our init.pi file
and now we'll do util.pi
and we'll start by importing Pica and
Json
and we'll Define a function called
upload and remember the parameters are
the file our grid FS instance our
rabbitmq Channel and our access which is
the user's access
now this function is going to be a
little bit complicated so try to keep up
and pay attention I'll try to explain
things the best that I can so basically
with this upload function needs to do is
it needs to First upload the file to our
mongodb database using gridfs and once
the file has been successfully uploaded
we need to put a message in our rabbitmq
so that a downstream service when they
pull that message from the queue can
process the upload by pulling it from
the mongodb and this queue is allowing
us to create an asynchronous
communication flow between our Gateway
service and the service that actually
processes our videos and this
asynchronicity is going to allow us to
avoid the need for our Gateway service
to wait for an internal service to
process the video before being able to
return a response to the client so the
first thing that we want to do is we
want to try to put our file into the
mongodb so when we put a file in the
mongodb we're going to use this FS dot
put function and it's going to be the
file that we want to put
and if this put is successful a file ID
is going to be returned a file ID object
to be more specific so mongodb is going
to return a file ID and that's if it's
successful but if it's not successful
then we want to catch the error
and for now we're just going to return
internal server error
and if this returns this means our file
wasn't uploaded successfully and the
function just returned so we don't need
to do anything else after that but if
the file was successfully uploaded we
need to create a message to put onto our
queue so we'll set message equal to
a dictionary and it's going to contain
the video file ID which is going to be
the file ID object converted into a
string
and we also need to create an empty MP3
file ID within this same dictionary and
for now it's going to be none but
Downstream it's going to end up being
set to the mp3s file ID in the database
but you don't need to think too much
about this right now we'll get to it
later
and we need to also have the username to
identify who owns the file and the
username is going to come from our
access from our auth service and
remember there was a claim for username
there which contains our user's email
and remember in our auth DB the email
must be unique so this is a way to
uniquely identify our user so that's
going to be our message and now we need
to put that message on the Queue so
we're going to try and put this message
on the queue
using the channel that's passed to the
function and we're going to do basic
publish
and we're going to set exchange equal to
an empty string and this is just going
to mean we're going to use the default
exchange so I will explain a bit more
about how rabbitmq works so for our
purposes we're going to use a very basic
rapidmq configuration and setup but we
need to go over a couple of things so
that we have a clear understanding of
what's Happening Here let's start with
the top level overview of how rabbitmq
integrates with our system the first
thing that is important to understand is
that our producer which is the service
that is putting the message on the Queue
isn't publishing the message directly to
the queue it actually sends messages
through an exchange The Exchange is
basically a middleman that allocates
messages to their correct queue
throughout the video I've been referring
to rabbitmq as if it were a single cue
but under the hood we actually can and
do configure multiple cues within one
rabbitmq instance for example in our
case we'll make use of both a cue that
we'll call video and a queue that we'll
call MP3 so when our producer publishes
a message to The Exchange The Exchange
will route the message to the correct
queue based on some criteria so how does
our Exchange Route messages to the
correct queue in our case well since
we're going with a simple rabbitmq
configuration for the sake of brevity
you'll remember that we are using the
default exchange by setting the exchange
to an empty string and if we take a look
at the rabbitmq documentation here the
default exchange is a direct exchange
with no name EG the empty string
pre-declared by the broker and broker
just being our rapidm queue instance and
this default exchange has one special
property that makes it very useful for
simple applications and that is that
every queue that is created is
automatically bound to the default
exchange with a routing key which is the
same as the Q name so what does that
mean exactly simply put that just means
that we can set our routing key to the
name of the queue that we want our
message to be directed to and set the
exchange to the default exchange and
that will result in our message going to
the queue specified by the routing key
so with this overview we can see our
video queue the exchange our producer
and our consumer so let's say that this
producer is our Gateway service and this
queue is our video queue and this
consumer is our video to MP3 converter
when the user uploads a video our
Gateway stores the video and then
publishes a message to The Exchange that
is designated for the video queue The
Exchange will route that message to the
video queue and the downstream service
which is the consumer of the video queue
will process the message the consumer in
this case is our video to MP3 converter
service so it will process the message
by pulling the video from mongodb
converting it to MP3 storing the MP3 on
mongodb and then publishing a message to
The Exchange that is intended for the
MP3 queue but let's not focus on the
mp3q just yet we'll get to that later
let's just focus on the video queue for
now let's say for example our producer
is paddling on more messages than our
one consumer can process in a timely
manner this is where the capability to
scale up our video to MP3 consumer comes
into the picture but if we're going to
scale up our queue actually needs to be
able to accommodate multiple instances
of our consumer without bottlenecking
the entire flow so how do we manage that
we manage that by making use of a
pattern called the competing consumers
pattern this pattern simply enables
multiple concurrent consumers to process
messages received on the same messaging
channel that way if our queue is packed
full of messages we can scale up our
consumers to process the messages
concurrently resulting in more
throughput luckily by default our rapidm
QQ will dispatch messages to our
consuming services using the round robin
algorithm which satisfies our needs this
basically just means that the messages
will be distributed more or less evenly
amongst our consumers for example if we
have two instances of our consuming
service the first message would go to
this instance and if another message
were to come in it would not go to the
same instance it would go to the next
one and the same goes for if we already
have a bunch of messages on the Queue
the distribution of the messages will
essentially go in a sequence from one
instance of the consumer to the next to
the next and then back to the first Etc
so basically the messages will be
distributed evenly in a round robin
fashion so that they can be processed
concurrently and that is going to be
that so now that that's out of the way
let's get back to right adding our code
and then we're going to set our routing
key equal to video
so the routing key is actually going to
be the name of our queue and we're going
to have a queue called video where we
put the video messages on
and then the body of the message is
going to be Json dot dumps
message
now similar to
json.loads this dumps converts a python
object into a Json string
so as you can see it serializes the
object a python object to a Json
formatted string so it's basically doing
the opposite of Json loads because the
message we need to have a string
contained within it not a python object
and the python object I'm talking about
is this here this is being converted
into a Json string
which is going to be the body of our
message which gives our Downstream
service all of the information that it
needs to process the video conversion
and we need to also set properties equal
to Pika dot basic properties
and within these properties we need to
set the delivery mode
and that's going to be set to pica.spec
dot persistent
delivery
mode
and this part is very important to make
sure that our messages are persisted in
our queue in the event of a pod crash or
a restart of our pod so since our pod
for our rabbitmq is a stateful pod
within the kubernetes cluster we need to
make sure that when messages are added
to the queue they're actually persisted
so that if the Pod is reset or the Pod
fails when it comes back up or spins
back up the messages are still there
because if we don't set this if the Pod
crashes or is reset then the messages
are all going to be gone once the Pod is
restored back to its original state so
what we're essentially going to need to
do is we're going to need to make our
cue durable which means that the queue
is going to be retained even after a pod
restart and we need to make sure the
messages within the queue are also
durable which means that the messages
are going to be retained even in the
event of a pod restart or crash so when
we actually create the queue we can
configure the queue to be durable
but that doesn't mean that the messages
are going to also be persisted it just
means that the queue will be durable so
each individual message that we send to
the queue we need to set this
configuration here to tell rabbitmq that
the message should be persisted until
the message has been removed from the
queue
so anyways we're going to try to put our
message onto our queue and if that
doesn't work out
we need to first delete the file from
our mongodb because if there's no
message on the queue for the file but
the file still exists in the DB that
file is never going to get processed
because the downstream service doesn't
know that that file exists if it never
receives a message telling it to process
that file so we'll just end up with a
bunch of stale files in the database if
we don't delete them in the event that a
message can't be put onto our queue so
if the message is unsuccessfully added
to the queue we'll do fs.delete and we
need to delete using the file ID
and the file ID is the file ID object
not the string it's defined here
and once we've deleted the file we can
then return internal server
error
so in this case in the event of a
failure
we will neither have a message on the
Queue telling the downstream service to
process the file and we will also not
have a file in our database so it's
going to be a complete failure so we can
just return internal server error and at
that point the user could just upload
the file again if they want to try again
and this is going to be it for our
upload function
and we're not using this error variable
yet but we might use it later on down
the line Depending on time constraints
so we'll just leave it for now
so let's go ahead and save and quit and
we can clear okay so at this point we
can go back to our root directory and we
can start creating the deployment for
this Gateway service so to start we just
want to go ahead and freeze our
requirements our dependencies into a
requirements.txt file and we can start
to create our Docker file now our Docker
file is going to be quite similar to the
one that we used for our auth service so
we can actually just go to our auth
service
and get this Docker file and paste it
into this one
and everything is pretty much going to
remain the same except for we're going
to change the exposed port to 8080 and
we also don't need this here but other
than that the file is going to be
identical so we can just go ahead and
save this so now let's go ahead and
build our image so we'll do Docker build
and once we've built the image similar
to before we can go ahead and tag our
image so we'll do Docker tag and we'll
go ahead and take the beginning of this
and paste it in and your username for
your Docker Hub account and this time
instead of auth we're going to say
Gateway
and latest
now at this point on your Docker Hub
account you'll only have one repository
which is the repository for our auth
service and if we want to we can just
create the Gateway repository manually
but it'll actually create itself once we
push to our username with the suffix
Gateway
so if we just do docker
push
and username slash forward slash Gateway
latest
you'll see that if you refresh the page
here
it automatically created the Gateway
repository for us and if we go in here
we'll see that we pushed the tag latest
a few seconds ago so now we have our
Gateway repository in our Docker Hub
account
so now that we can pull the image
containing our source for our Gateway
service from the internet we can go
ahead and create our kubernetes manifest
directory and we can go ahead and change
there into there and similar again to
our auth service we need to create a
Gateway deployment yaml file
and this configuration is also going to
be very similar to our off service
and this time we're going to pull our
image from the Gateway Repository
so remember your username and then
Gateway
and similar to the auth service we're
going to create a config map
called Gateway config map and let's not
make the same mistake as last time this
should be indented
and for our secret ref we're going to
create a secret as well
and that's going to be it for our
deployment
and now let's go ahead and make our
config map
and the data that we need for our
environment variables we need our auth
service address
and in kubernetes the service name will
resolve to that service's host IP
address so we can just put auth and then
the port that the service is available
at so we'll do all 5000 and that's going
to be the address of our auth service
within our kubernetes cluster and we can
go ahead and save that and now let's
create our secret
and as of right now I don't think we
have secrets for our Gateway service so
let's just put a placeholder here for
now and later we can add any secret
variables if we need to
and let's save that and we need to
create service.yaml
and the name of our service will just be
Gateway
and this service will have an internal
IP address which will only be available
within our cluster but our Gateway API
needs to be able to be accessed from
outside of our cluster so we're actually
going to need to create another
configuration called an Ingress to Route
traffic to our actual Gateway service
which I will get into in a second so we
need to set ports equal to
80 80
Target port 8080 as well
and protocol is of course TCP
so now we'll create the ingress.yaml
which is going to allow traffic to
access our Gateway endpoint so let's
take a second to understand what an
Ingress is in the context of a
kubernetes cluster okay so in order to
understand what an Ingress is in the
context of kubernetes you first need to
understand what a service is in the
context of kubernetes so with this
configuration file we're creating a
service and you can really just think of
the service as a group of PODS so in our
case we want to create the Gateway
service and we want that service to be
able to scale up to multiple instances
or multiple pods so the service comes in
and groups all of the instances of our
Gateway service together and it does
this by using a selector so in our case
we're using this label selector to tell
our service what pods are part of its
group or under its umbrella so this
label selector essentially by lines our
pods to the service so any pod with this
label will be recognized by the service
as being part of its group so now we
don't have to think about individual IPS
for each individual pod and we don't
have to worry about keeping track of the
IPS of PODS that go down or are
recreated we also don't have to think
about how requests to our service are
load balanced to individual pods the
service abstracts all of this away from
us so now we can just send requests to
the services cluster IP which remember
is its internal IP and we can assume
that these requests will be distributed
logically amongst our pods based on
something like round robin for example
which we already went over when
explaining webinimq so now that we have
a clear picture of a service we can get
into what an Ingress is so we have our
service with its pods and that service
sits in our cluster which is our private
network but we need to allow quests from
outside of our cluster to hit our
Gateway Services endpoints we do this by
making use of an Ingress simply put an
Ingress consists of a load balancer that
is essentially the entry point to our
cluster and a set of rules those rules
basically say which requests go where
for example we have a rule that says
that any request that hits our load
balancer via the domain name
mp3converter.com should be routed to our
Gateway service so since this load
balancer is the entry point to our
cluster it can actually Route traffic to
the cluster IPS within the cluster so in
this case it would route requests going
to the configured MP3 converter.com
domain to our Gateway Services internal
cluster IP and if we wanted to we could
even add a rule to our Ingress that says
to Route requests to apples.com to a
different service in our cluster for
example so that's pretty much everything
you need to know about Ingress for the
purposes of this video so let's get into
writing our Ingress configuration file
so for the API version we're going to
set
networking.kh dot IO V1 and kind is
going to be Ingress this time
and we're going to name it
Gateway Ingress and we're going to use
the default Ingress which is basically
an nginx Ingress and we can set some
configurations for our nginx Ingress
using this annotations key and we want
to make sure that our Ingress allows the
upload of some relatively large files so
we're just going to set our Ingress
body size to zero which is essentially
going to allow any body size and of
course you want to fine-tune
configurations like these in a
production application but again our
focus is the overall architecture so
we're basically just configuring this in
the easy way possible to get things done
and this is a typo
and we're going to do two more
configurations
proxy
read time out and we're going to set
that equal to 600
and proxy
same time out and we'll also set that
one to 600. now for our spec
and the rules we're going to Route
request to the host MP3 converter
.com to our Gateway service
so remember our service name is Gateway
and our service is available at Port
8080.
so you're probably wondering how our
kubernetes cluster knows if we're making
a request to this host and basically
what we're going to do is we're going to
make it so that requests to this host on
our local machine gets routed to the
Local Host so we're just going to map
this hostname to localhost on our local
machine and we're going to Tunnel
requests to our Local Host to minicube
which sounds a bit complicated but just
bear with me and we'll get to it so
we're going to save this file and first
we need to make sure that the MP3
converter.com gets routed to localhost
so you need to open a file called
Etc hosts
and you're going to have to have pseudo
permissions to do that
so once in this directory you want to
map this address
127.0.0.1 which is the loopback address
which localhost also resolves to we want
to map it to
MP3 converter.com
so once we do this whenever we enter
This MP3 converter.com into our browser
or if we send a request to this host
it's going to resolve to localhost
so we can go ahead and save that
and now we need to configure a mini Cube
add-on to allow Ingress so we'll do mini
Cube add-ons and let's list the add-ons
that are available
and as you can see there's an Ingress
add-on here that's currently disabled
so we can do mini Cube add-ons Ingress
enable I believe
or we can do
enable Ingress
and once that's done as you can see here
it says that after the add-on is enabled
please run minicube tunnel and your
Ingress resources would be available at
this loopback address that we mapped to
mp3converter.com so basically whenever
we want to use our microservice
architecture or test this overall
architecture we're going to run this
mini Cube tunnel command
and while this is running whenever we
send requests to our loopback address
they're going to go to our mini Cube
cluster via the Ingress and since we
mapped mp3converter.com to our loopback
address if we send requests to MP3
converter.com they're going to go to
this mini Cube tunnel so just keep in
mind so we control C out of this
whenever we
cancel this process then we're no longer
tunneling the Ingress so as you can see
here it says please do not close this
terminal as this process must stay alive
for the tunnel to be accessible so
whenever we test we're going to have to
run this mini Cube tunnel basically and
we'll get to end-to-end testing a little
bit later we're not going to test yet
until we configure our q and our
consumer service as well as our Gateway
service which will be the producer
service and that is how we are going to
Route requests into our cluster and
directly to our API Gateway so if we go
and check K9s
you may or may not see these two new
items here but if you remember we've
only deployed our auth service so far so
we still need to deploy this Gateway
service and similar to the off service
we're going to have two replicas of our
Gateway deployed so we can quit this and
we can attempt to apply our
configuration that we have here
and it looks like we have an issue here
so let's go into our secrets file and it
looks like we forgot to capitalize
Secret
so let's once again try to apply
and as you can see all of the resources
or the objects were created successfully
so let's go into canines
and we're having an error with pulling
the image here so let's see
so it's actually not in error with
pulling the image so the Gateway is
failing because we basically don't have
the rabbitmq queue deployed yet and it's
trying to connect to this host here that
we haven't yet created so that's fine
for now so for now it's not going to be
able to deploy so actually so it's not
continuously running let's just scale
that down for now until we create our
rabbit mqq deployment so we can do Cube
CTL scale and we can do deployment and
we want to change the replicas to zero
and we want to do that for the Gateway
service so it says that our Gateway
service was scaled so now you can see
the the Gateway service is gone now it's
not trying to be scaled up currently
because we need to create that rabbitmq
so let's go ahead and quit and from here
we can start to get into the rabbitmq
stuff so we need to create and deploy a
rabbit and Q container to our kubernetes
cluster so we're just going to change
directory back to our source directory
and currently we have our auth directory
and our Gateway directory now we need to
make a directory for our rabbitmq so
we're just going to call it rabbit
and we'll CD into rabbit and for rabbit
mq instead of making a deployment like
we did for the other two Services we're
going to need to make a stateful set
because we want our cue to remain intact
even if the Pod crashes or restarts we
want the messages within the queue to
stay persistent until they've been
pulled from the queue so let me go ahead
and explain what a stateful set is okay
so a staple set is similar to a
deployment in that it manages the
deployment and scaling of a set of PODS
and these pods are based on an identical
container spec but unlike a deployment
with a staple set each pod has a
persistent identifier that it maintains
across any rescheduling this means that
if a pod fails the persistent pod
identifiers make it easier to match
existing volumes to the new pods that
replace any that have failed and this is
important because if we were to have
multiple instances of say for example a
MySQL server each individual instance
would reference its own physical storage
and actually there would be a master pod
that is able to actually persist data to
its physical storage and the rest of the
pods would be slaves and they would only
be able to read the data from their
physical storage and the physical
storage that the slave pods use
basically continuously syncs with the
master pods physical storage because
that's where all of the data persistence
happens and most of the details
surrounding this are not related to our
architecture so I'll spare you the
details actually to be honest there's
probably a better way to configure our
rapidmq broker within our cluster but
this configuration will work just fine
for our purposes we'll only be making
use of one replica to achieve the before
mentioned competing consumers pattern
anyways the most important configuration
that you need to understand for this
particular service is how we are going
to be persisting the data in our cues
remember that if our instance fails we
don't want to lose all of the messages
that haven't been processed because then
the users that uploaded those videos
that produce those messages would just
never hear back from us so basically
what we want to do is we want to mount
the physical storage on our local to The
Container instance and if the container
instance happens to die for whatever
reason of course the storage volume that
was mounted would remain intact then
when a new pod is redeployed it will
once again have that same physical
storage mounted to it so let me show you
what I mean by that to show you this
I'll need to show you what the
configuration file for our staple set is
going to look like although we haven't
written the code for this file yet just
follow along so that you can understand
where we're going with this so as you
can see this configuration file follows
a similar pattern to what all of the
other configuration files did so I'm not
going to go into detail about every
single line if you need to please refer
to the kubernetes API documentation that
I introduced to you earlier but let's go
ahead and have a look at containers here
similar to our deployments this is going
to determine the contain painter that
gets spun up so the image we're using
here is a rapidmq image but the part
that we need to pay attention to starts
here at this volume mounts Mount path so
we want to mount a storage volume to our
container right this Mount path is
configuring where in our container we
want the physical storage volume to
mount to so basically anything that is
saved in this VAR lib rabbitmq directory
within our container we'll actually be
getting saved to the physical storage
volume that will persist even if the
container fails and this particular
directory is configured as the mount
path for a reason this is actually where
rabbitmq is going to store the cues when
we create a durable cue and the messages
when we configure them to be persistent
and I'm going to go into detail about
how we make the queue durable and the
messages persistent a little bit later
for now you just need to understand that
we're mounting physical storage to this
path and this is the path where rabbitmq
will save cues and messages okay so now
that that's out of the way the rest of
the configure duration here under
volumes is basically just the
configuration for the physical volume to
be mounted to the container for example
we need to create an additional resource
called a persistent volume claim and
this config here basically links this
staple set to the persistent volume
claim that we're going to create and
we're going to call that persistent
volume claim rabbitmq PVC so what is a
persistent volume claim in simple terms
the persistent volume claim or PVC is
going to be bound to a persistent volume
and within the configuration for the
persistent volume claim we'll set how
much storage we want to make available
to it from the persistent volume and the
persistent volume will actually be what
interacts with the actual physical
storage and I know there are many layers
of abstraction here but again for our
purposes we really don't need to go into
too much detail here all you really need
to understand is that this configuration
is going to make it so that the dura
rabbitmq stores cues and messages will
actually be persistent storage so
whenever the Pod dies those cues and
messages will be retained and the new
pod will just reconnect to that
persistent volume so let's go ahead and
write up this configuration so now that
we have an understanding what a staple
set is we can go ahead and create a file
called stateful set.yaml and actually
we're going to want to make this in a
manifest directory so we'll just make
their manifest
and CD into manifests and then we'll
create the stateful set.yaml file
in the here we'll set API version to
apps V1 and this time kind is going to
be stateful set
and metadata
will name
rabbitmq and our spec configuration so
the service name we're not going to use
this
so we'll just set it to not applicable
and selector match labels as usual app
rabbitmq now for our template and this
is similar to the deployment it's going
to be the template for our pods and
we'll do metadata
labels app is rabbit mq and our template
spec or the Pod spec to be more specific
through containers
name
rabbitmq and image is going to be rabbit
mq
three management and this is the
official rabbitmq image and we're adding
this management we're using the one that
contains management because we want to
have the graphical user interface to
manage our cues as well included in the
image
and then we need to set ports and this
container is going to need to include
two ports we need the port to access the
graphical user interface and we also
need the port that handles the actual
messages for example the messages that
we send to the queue are going to be
handled on a separate Port from the port
that handles our connection to the
graphical user interface and you'll see
what I mean by that so we're going to
set the name of this port the first port
to http
because we're going to use HTTP to
access the graphical user interface
and protocol
will be TCP and container Port is going
to be one five six seven two
and we're also going to need a port for
amqp which stands for advanced message
queuing protocol and this is just the
protocol that we use to send messages to
the queue
and container Port here is going to just
be five six seven two
and after ports we'll do environment
from and we're still going to use config
map
and we'll call it rabbitmq config map
and secret ref name will be rabbitmq
secret
and we're also going to need a key
called volume mounts
and we need to specify the mount path
and this is going to be the path within
the container that we want mounted
so we'll do VAR
lib
rapid mq and the rabbitmq server is
going to store the persisted data like
the messages and the cues in this
directory or at this path so we want to
mount this path to our volume and our
volume is essentially going to be
storage that we connect to our
kubernetes cluster which is where
persisted data is going to be stored
so name will be rabbitmq volume
So within spec at the same level as
containers
we're going to do volumes
name
rabbit mq volume
and we're going to use persistent
volume claim and claim name will be
rabbitmq PVC which we need to create and
that's going to be it for this stateful
set configuration
so we can save that so now we need to
create our persistent volume claim so
we're going to do pvc.yaml
and we'll do API version
P1 and kind this time is going to be
persistent
volume claim
and metadata
we're going to do name rabbit mq PVC
which we just referenced in our stateful
set file and spec and access modes is
going to be read write once
resources requests
storage
one gigabyte and storage class
name will be standard
and we can save that and as usual we
need to create our service.yaml
API version V1 kind service
metadata name of the service will be
rabbitmq
and our spec so type again is going to
be cluster IP our service is only going
to have an internal IP address which is
only accessible within our cluster and
selector
app rabbitmq
and ports
remember that uh ports we're going to
need to have the port for our graphical
user interface so basically the rabbitmq
like Management console and then we need
the port for actual message transmission
so we'll do ports name http
protocol
TCP and we're just going to do port
15672
and we'll do Target Port is the same
and then we'll do our port for our
message transmission which will be amqp
again and we'll do protocol
TCP and this one's going to be Port 5672
and Target board is the same port and we
can save that and actually one second we
need to go back in here so as you can
see we're going to need to allow access
to this port from a web browser so we're
going to need to allow access from
outside of the cluster directly to this
port so that we can access rabbitmq's
Management console so to do that we need
to create an Ingress for this port as
well
so let's go ahead and quit and do Vim
Ingress and we'll do
API version
networking.kh.iov1
and kind is going to be Ingress
and a data name rabbit mq Ingress
and spec
rules and host and we're going to do it
at
rabbitmqmanager.com which we need to
configure in our Etc host file
and it's going to be http
aths and path
type prefix
back end
service and the back end service is
going to be rabbit in queue
more specifically rabbitmq's port number
15672 which is the port number for the
Management console
so we can save that and we need to open
this file again
and we're basically going to do the same
configuration but it's going to be for
rabbit
mqmanager.com I think that's what we
called it
yeah
rabbitmqmanager.com
so we can close that save this and close
it
and let's make a config map and I don't
think we currently need any
environment variables but let's just
make a template
just in case we need to add some
and we'll do the same thing for a secret
and that should be everything so let's
go ahead and try and apply this
so we have a couple of Errors the first
one here is just a spelling error so
config map I misspelled the key metadata
so let's go in there and fix that
meta data
and let's apply again and in the
service.yaml it's saying that the API
version is not set so let's go and
service.yaml and that's because I put
ape version
so API version and let's apply again
and it says that
stapleset.spec.templetunknown field
volumes and that's because volumes
should be at the same level as spec so
let's go into stapleset.yaml
actually the issue is the opposite of
what I said volumes should be at the
same level as container
so it's under spec
so we need to move this in one
so let's save that
and let's apply again and now it seems
all of the objects were created
successfully so let's go into canines
and we see that our rabbitmq pod is
pending and let's go have a look
and it seems something's not working as
expected so let's do
subscribe pod rabbitmq and we have an
event here warning failed scheduling one
pod has Unbound immediate persistent
volume claims
okay so it seems there's an issue with
our PVC so let's go ahead and do qctl
describe
PVC
and we have another event here warning
provisioning failed it says storage
class storage uh stranded
so it can't find the storage class
because the storage class is standard
and I have a typo so let's go ahead and
Vim into our PVC file and here is the
error it should be standard so let's
save that
and let's apply again
and actually for persistent volume
claims as said here the spec for this is
immutable after creation so we're
actually going to have to delete the
resources created using these files and
we only really need to delete the
persistent volumes claim but it doesn't
matter we'll just delete all of the
resources created with this file or
created with these files so basically
we're going to use this Cube CTL delete
command
and we're going to have the flag f for
files and we're going to delete all the
resources created with the files within
this directory so let's just delete them
all and now that we're done deleting
them we can just go ahead and apply them
again
and it seems they're created
successfully so we can go into canines
and it looks like the container is
creating
and it looks like everything is going as
expected so let's leave the logs and
leave the container so yeah now we have
our rapidmq instance running within our
kubernetes cluster
let's go ahead and quit since we
configured an Ingress for this and we
configured this route
in our Etc hosts file
we should be able to access
rabbitmqmanager.com and that should take
us to the rabbitmq manager so let's try
that
so let's go ahead and go to
rabbitmqmanager.com
it's not working because we forgot to do
mini Cube tunnel so let's go ahead and
clear this and do mini Cube tunnel
and as you can see here it's trying to
start a tunnel service for both our
Gateway Ingress and our rabbit mq
Ingress so let's see if we can access
the Management console now
so let's just refresh this page and I'm
just going to accept the risk and there
we go we have access to our Management
console and let me just go ahead and
zoom in here so the username and the
password for this should just be admin
and login failed so maybe that's not the
correct credentials
so let's just go to Google and type in
rabbitmq Management
console default
credentials
and here it actually says the username
and password are both guest so let's try
that
so we'll do guest and guest and there we
go we are logged in zoomed in a little
bit too much
and this is what the Management console
is going to look like
and you don't need to get overwhelmed by
all of this we're going to limit our
Focus to just this cues section so for
example we're going to create our cues
here using this add a new queue
and yeah so we're going to make use of
two cues one of them is going to be
called video which is going to be the
queue where we put our video messages
and let me just show you to give you a
bit of a refresher so remember while
we're actually using our Ingress we
can't exit this so we're going to need
to open up a new terminal or a new tab
so I'll just open a new tab
and I'll zoom in here
and I'll just change directory to
system design python Source rabbits
and actually what I wanted to show you
is in the Gateway directory so
in our server.pi when we upload
we use this util.upload and in here
we're putting the message on the Queue
called video so routing key is just the
queue so in the console here we actually
need to create that cue so we're going
to create a cue called video and this
durability needs to be set to durable
because if it's transient then that
means that if the container is restarted
or shut down or anything the queues no
longer going to exist you're going to
need to create it again so durable means
that the queue will be essentially
persisted so if the container restarts
or something the queue will still exist
afterwards
so we'll just add this cue
so now we have our video queue here
so now let's see if we can start up our
Gateway server
so we can just quit here
and canines
quickly
so yeah we want to spit up our Gateway
service so we'll go ahead and let's just
change directory into Gateway manifest
and we'll do Cube CTL apply we'll apply
all of the files in this directory
and let's do canines again
and as you can see now our Gateway
service is able to start up with no
issues
so at this point we have our Gateway
service and our off service and our
rabbitmq queue service up and running
within our cluster so that means that
right now we can upload files and
messages for those uploads will be added
to the queue and at this point we have
no consumer service to consume the
messages from the queue to actually
convert the files so we need to create
an additional service and this service
is going to pull messages off of the
queue that the Gateway adds to the queue
and it's going to convert them into MP3
and then it's going to store the MP3 and
mongodb and put a message onto another
queue called MP3 which will have another
Downstream service pull from but I don't
want to confuse you all too much so
let's just do this step by step
so we can leave this
and we need to go back to our source
directory because we need to create
another service so we're going to make
dur converter and this converter service
is going to convert videos to MP3 so
this is going to be the consumer service
that pulls the messages off the queue so
it knows which videos it needs to
convert and where they're stored Etc so
we'll make this directory and we'll just
CD into that directory and let's clear
and we're going to make a file called
consumer.pi
and in this file we're going to import
Pica of course because we need to pull
the messages off the queue sys OS time
and from PI [ __ ] we need to import
[ __ ] client
and that's not how you spell import
and we also need to import grid FS
because we need to take the files from
mongodb to video files and we also need
to upload the MP3 files to mongodb and
from convert which is a package that
we're going to create ourselves we're
going to import to MP3 which is going to
be of a module within that package
and we're just going to define a
function called Main and our client is
going to be equal to mongodb client and
it's going to be our mongodb host which
is on our local machine it's not
deployed in our cluster remember so we
need to use this host
mini Cube internal which basically gives
us access to our host systems local
environment and the port for mongodb is
27017
and we're going to do DB Videos equals
client dot videos so this instance of
[ __ ] client is going to give us access
to the DBS that we have in our [ __ ]
database so we can do DB MP3s
equals client Dot
MP3s so these databases will exist
within our mongodb
and then we need our grid FS stuff
so we'll do FS videos
equals an instance of grid FS
which we need to pass our DB Videos to
and fsmp3s we need to do the same thing
and now we need to configure our rabbit
mq connection
so connection will equal
Pika dot blocking connection just like
before
and we'll do Pica dot connection
[Music]
parameters
host equals rabbit mq
and this is possible because our service
name is rabbit and Q and our service
name will resolve to the host IP for our
rabbitmq service
and channel will equal
connection.channel
so what we need to do is we need to
create a configuration to consume the
messages from our video queue and to do
that we're going to use this Channel and
basic consume
and let's save this
and the arguments that we need to pass
to this basic consume is our q and we're
going to get the Q name from the
environment so the queue that we want to
consume from in this case is the video
queue but just in case we want to change
it in the future we're going to just
have an environment variable that
contains our Q configuration so we'll do
OS Dot
environ.git and we'll name the
environment variable video queue
so that's going to be our q and we're
going to need to create a callback
function that gets executed whenever a
message is pulled off of the queue so
we'll say on message
callback equals callback and we need to
create this callback function so we'll
go up here and Define callback
so whenever a message is taken off the
queue by this consumer service this
callback function is going to be
executed
and it's going to be executed with the
parameters Channel method
properties and body
and what we want to do when we get the
message is we want to convert the video
to MP3 so we'll do two MP3 dot start
so there's going to be a function in our
two MP3 module called start and we're
going to pass in the body of our message
and we're going to pass in FS videos and
Fs mp3s and the channel and when we
create this function you're going to see
why we're doing all of this but for now
we're just creating the Callback
function that's going to call this
function so we're going to set the
result to error and if there is an error
so if error so if there is an error we
want to send a negative acknowledgment
to the channel
so we'll do basic
Knack which stands for negative
acknowledgment which basically means
that we're not going to acknowledge that
we've received and processed the message
so the message won't be removed from the
queue because we want to keep messages
on the Queue if there's a failure to
process them so they can be processed
later by another process and here we're
going to do delivery
tag equals method dot delivery
tag
and this delivery tag uniquely
identifies the delivery on a channel so
when we send this negative
acknowledgment to the Channel with the
delivery tag rabbitmq knows which
delivery tag or which message hasn't
been acknowledged so it'll know not to
remove that message from the queue but
on the other hand if the error is none
then that means there wasn't an issue
with the conversion
so we'll just go ahead and acknowledge
the message so we'll do basic
pack for acknowledgment and same thing
we're going to do
delivery Tech is method.deliverytag and
if you see here method is one of the
parameters that's passed to the Callback
function and that's how we're keeping
track of the delivery tag so that's it
for our callback function and let's go
ahead and format
and we'll go ahead and print a message
that just says waiting for messages
and we can also put to exit press
control plus c
and basically once we run this uh main
function here this is going to be
printed and then we're going to do
Channel dot start consuming
and this start consuming is essentially
going to run our consumer so our
consumer is going to be listening to the
queue or listening on that channel where
our video messages are being put so we
need to do if name equals
Main
we're going to try and run our main
function
and we're going to do accept
keyboard interrupt
so our main function is going to run
until we press Ctrl C and interrupt the
process
and once that process is interrupted
with bias pressing Ctrl C then that
event is going to be captured in this
try except and we're going to catch the
keyboard interrupt which is US pressing
Ctrl C to cancel the consumer process
and in that case we'll just print
interrupted
and we'll try sis.exit
and
we'll accept
system exit and then we'll do OS dot
exit
zero and this is basically us just
gracefully shutting down the actual
service in the event that we do a
keyboard interrupt
and that is going to be it for our
consumer so we need to go and create
this convert package and this two MP3
module and we also need to install some
things and we also forgot to create a
virtual environment so let's go ahead
and save this
and let's go ahead and do python
3
p e and B
and now we can activate our virtual
environment
so
Source then activate
and we now are using our converter
virtual environment and now we can just
cat consumer
dot pi
or maybe it's better to do cat
head
in 10. so we need to install some of
these dependencies so we'll do fifth
three install
Pica and Pi [ __ ]
and actually I don't need the comma
there so pip3 install Pika and Pi [ __ ]
and let's go in here
and it looks like we're good to go so
let's clear so now we need to create our
convert package so we'll just make dare
convert
and change directory into convert and we
need to create the init.pi file and we
need to create a module called to MP3
and then we're going to need to import a
couple of things so we'll import Pica as
usual and we need to import Json as well
and we need to import temp file which I
will show you what that's going to be
used for in a second and Os as well and
we need to import this binary Json dot
object ID
and from there we need to import object
ID and I'll show you what this is doing
or what this is going to be used for
soon as well
and lastly we need to import this movie
Pi editor
which we need to install
and we're going to define a function
called start and it's going to take in a
message a gridfs videos instance a grid
FS MP3s instance
and a channel
and for now let's pass so we can go
ahead and recap
so just to recap if we go into our
consumer.pi file
we're importing this module that we just
created
to MP3 and this two MP3 module contains
the start function which is the one that
we're creating now
so we're going to be using this movie
pie
to convert our videos to MP3 so we're
going to need to install pip install
movie pi
and from there we can start writing the
code for our start function
so the first thing that we're going to
need to do is we're going to need to
load our message
which is essentially going to make it
into a python object
so let me just install something really
quick
so we're going to deserialize an
instance containing a Json document to a
python object
so at this point our message contains
the python object version of our message
and the first thing that we want to do
before converting the file is we want to
create an empty temporary file and we're
going to write our video contents to
that temporary file so we'll do empty
temp file is TF so we'll do TF equals
temp file dot named temporary file and
as you can see here it says create and
return a temporary file and this
temporary file is going to be a named
temporary file as opposed to a temporary
file that does not have a name
so if we go to this definition here
you can see that this temporary file has
a name attribute where you can access
the file's name so we're going to create
this named temporary file and it's
essentially going to create a temp file
in attempt directory and we can use that
temp file to write our video data to
so we'll do video contents
and we'll set out equal to FS videos dot
get so now we're going to get our video
file from grid fs and we're going to
have it in this out variable or this out
object is going to have a read method so
we'll be able to write the data that's
stored in this out variable to the file
so we need to do object ID
and message
video fid
which if you remember from our Gateway
service
in the actual storage util function
we have video FID set to the file ID
that was given to us after we put the
video file into mongodb
but if you also remember we have to
convert that into a string because the
FID that comes from the return value of
this fs.put is actually an ID object
so we needed to convert it into a string
to put it into our message
so we're taking our string version of
our FID and converting it into an object
and then we need to use that object
version to get the file from our mongodb
we can't get the file using the string
version of the ID
so just really quick let's go ahead and
save that actually let's go back in here
and for some reason it says no name
object ID so
let's see
and I guess that's just an error so
so once we have the video file data we
can add video contents to empty file and
we're going to do that by taking the
empty file which is the TF variable and
we're going to write to that file the
data that's returned from this read
method and this is the read method on
the out variable or the out object as
this read method which allows us to read
the data stored in out
so if we go to the definition here we
can see that we can read the bytes from
the file so the bytes that are returned
from this read method here are going to
be written to our temporary file here
and then what we want to do is we want
to convert our video file into audio so
our temp file currently has the video
file so we'll do create audio from temp
video file
so audio is going to equal moviepi dot
editor Dot video file clip and then
we're going to take the TF or the
temporary file name
which is actually going to resolve to
the path of the temporary file and we're
going to extract the audio from that
file so all of this is going to resolve
to our audio file being stored in this
audio variable
and the last thing we need to do is we
need to close our temp file and with
this temp file module here the temp file
will automatically be deleted after
we're done with it so basically after we
close the file it will automatically be
deleted so we don't need to worry about
cleaning that up so now that we've
extracted the audio into the audio
variable we need to write the audio to
the file or to its own file and we're
going to do that by first creating a
path for our audio file so we'll do temp
file path equals temp file dot get
tempter and this is going to give us the
directory on our OS where the temp files
are being stored by this temp file
module so we'll take that dur and we'll
add it to our desired file name
so we're going to name it the video file
ID which we'll take from message
video file ID
.mp3 so what we're doing here is we're
first taking the path to our temp
directory and we're appending our
desired MP3 file name to that path so
we're left with the full path to the
file and we want to name the MP3 file
just the file ID of the video because
it's going to be a unique ID so in this
case we won't have to worry about
collisions with file names because every
video file is going to have a unique ID
and that's going to be the name of the
MP3 file as well so then we want to do
audio Dot right audio file and we're
going to write the file to the path that
we just created so we're taking our
audio file that was created using this
movie pi and this object is going to
have a method called Write audio file
and we basically just need to tell this
right audiophile method where we want to
write the file and what we want to name
the file so that's why we're just
passing this path that we created here
and once the audio file is created the
temporary audio file we can save the
file to [ __ ]
so first we need to open the file
so we'll open the file at the path we
just created and we just want to read
the file and we'll set data equal to
that file that we opened dot read and
then we'll set file ID equal to
fsmp3s dot put and then we're just going
to put that data that we extracted from
the file so we're storing our MP3 file
in our grid fs and at this point we
don't need that temp file anymore so
when we do F Dot close
we also need to go ahead and do OS dot
remove
TF path because remember in this case
this write audio file method created the
temporary file and not this temp file
module so we have to actually delete
this temp file manually ourselves
and lastly we need to update our message
and remember we have this MP3 FID in our
message and we want to set that equal to
string version of the FID object that we
got from uploading the MP3 to mongodb
and lastly we need to put this message
on a new cue or a different queue that
we need to create called the MP3 queue
so we'll do try Channel Dot
basic publish
and we'll use the default exchange Again
by just putting an empty string and our
routing key it's going to be mp3 for the
MP3 queue but remember we're going to
get those from the environment the names
of our cues from the environment so
we'll just call this environment
variable MP3 Q
and our body of course is going to be
Json dot dumps because we need to
convert the python object into Json and
our message will be the input
and we need to make sure the message is
persisted until it's processed so we'll
do
pica.basic properties
and we're going to once again like
before set the delivery mode equal to
pica.spec dot persistent delivery mode
and if we can't put the message on our
queue
and let's just catch the exception as an
error
just in case we need that variable and
then we'll do FS MP3s dot delete
FID so basically if we can't
successfully put the message on the
Queue saying that there's an MP3
available for that message then we want
to delete the actual MP3 from mongodb as
well because if we don't put the message
on the Queue then the file in mongodb
the MP3 will never get processed anyway
so we need to make sure we remove the
MP3 from mongodb if we can't add the
message to the queue and in that case
we're just going to return
failed to publish message
and the reason this will work is because
let's go ahead and
save this
if we go back into our consumer.pi file
if you remember
if this start function here fails then
we're going to return an error and that
error is going to be stored in this
error variable and if there is an error
then we're going to send a negative
acknowledgment for the actual message
that's on our video queue so that means
that that message will not be removed
from the queue and it can be processed
again later so that's why we need the
actual start method to fail completely
because we're going to basically attempt
this whole function again if something
goes wrong
so that's why we need to delete the file
from mongodb if we can't put the message
onto the queue
and let's just go ahead and format
and we can save that and that's going to
be it for our consumer
so what we need to do now is we need to
create our Docker file and our
kubernetes configuration to create the
service within our cluster so let's pip
freeze our requirements into a
requirements.txt file as usual and then
we'll create a Docker file and this
Docker file is once again going to be
the same as the previous Docker file
so we'll just copy this and paste it
here
and let's just save that
and we're going to need to add something
additional here called
ffmpeg which is just a dependency for
the movie Pi module and we need to
change this to consumer.pi
and we need to change our exposed to I
think Port 3000
and let's go ahead and save that
actually I made a mistake since this is
a consumer we're not going to expose any
port
because it's not going to be a service
that we're making requests to this
service is going to consume messages
from a queue
so it's going to act on its own so we'll
save that and let's do Docker build
and once that's done we can do Docker
tag
and we'll just take a piece of this
and we're going to use your username for
your Docker Hub account and this time
we'll call it converter
and latest
and then we can do Docker push
converter latest
and now if you go to your Docker Hub
account
foreign
you should see that you now have a
converter repository as well
and you should have the tag latest here
as well
so now we can make our manifest
directory
and for this one we just need to create
a yaml file for
the deployment
and the secret and the config map so
we're not going to need to create a
service configuration for this one
so we'll do API version
apps V1 kind deployment
metadata
name is converter
labels app converter
spec
and we'll do four replicas for this one
and selector
match labels
app converter
and strategy is going to be type rolling
update
and rolling update
Max surge we'll just double the number
of replicas
and now for the template
labels app converter
and we'll do spec
actually spec should go back here
and containers
name equals converter
and image is going to be your username
converter
and environment from will be
config map reference
and name is going to be converter config
map which we'll create
and we'll also do Secret ref
which will have the name Secret
or converter
Secret
and that's going to be it for that
so let's save and we'll create our
config map
and we'll set API version to V1
kind config map
metadata name
converter config map
and data so we need our mp3q name
because remember we're using the
environment variable to select the queue
in our code and we need our video queue
name
and actually while we're doing this we
need to go create our mp3q
so back in our Management console
we have our video Cube but we need to
create another queue so add new q and
we're just going to name it MP3 and it's
going to be a durable queue as well and
we'll just add Q
so now we have both the MP3 queue and
the video queue
and we can save this now we need to just
create our secret.yaml and we don't have
any secrets for this service so this is
just going to be a template file for now
foreign
let's save that and let's make some
space
so now let's go into canines and check
to see what we have running so far so we
have our auth service our Gateway and
our queue
so now we're trying to deploy our
consumer which is the converter
so we'll just apply all the files in the
current directory and it seems
everything was created so let's see if
we run into any issues
let's see if we can get a better view of
the logs so we'll do Cube CTL
logs follow
and just select one of these converters
and we're getting no module named binary
Json dot object ID so I must be pretty
sleepy because I don't know why I didn't
see this before but object ID here is
clearly missing a b
so let's go into our
convert
to MP3 file
and go over here and change this to
object ID
and we'll save that
change directory and just to double
check let's check to see if there's a
linting error
and go to definition so we're good to go
so we need to rebuild the docker file so
we'll do Docker build
and we need to update the repository so
we need to tag it again first of all
foreign
Docker push converter latest
and now that that's pushed let's once
again try to apply our configuration
that's in our manifest directory
and let's check canines
hmm actually let's try to let's first
um delete
and let's see if we can clear this out
really quick
and now let's
let's check to see if they're closing or
shutting down
okay we're good so now let's try Cube
CTL apply
and let's check canines
and let's see
well we got one two and three running
and four running so that's good news all
right so at this point we have our auth
service deployed we have uh multiple
instances of the converter service
deployed to pull from our rabbitmq which
we have deployed as well and we have our
Gateway deployed so at this point we can
see if uploading files results in
messages getting put on the Queue and we
can also see if those messages are being
pulled off of the queue by our converter
service and that'll probably be the most
difficult part to get configured because
once we have our uploads resulting in
the proper messages being put on the
Queue and the converter service
consuming those messages and converting
the videos and storing them in mongodb
that's pretty much the entire
functionality of this microservice
application so at that point we'll just
be creating a service to send
notifications when in p3s are finished
being converted or when videos are
finished being converted to MP3 so let's
test the end-to-end functionality of
uploading and having those uploads be
converted
so we can quit this and let's clear and
we still want our tunnel to be running
so make sure that your mini Cube tunnel
command is still running and you have
another tab opened to work with whatever
it is that we're working with at the
moment and we want to test by uploading
a video file and when we upload that
video file we want to see that the
message gets added to our video queue
and then gets removed from our video
queue and another message gets added to
our MP3 queue and we don't have a
consuming service to consume the mp3q
messages so all the messages should just
be piling up at the mp3q if our
end-to-end functionality is working as
expected and also if it's working as
expected we should be able to download a
converted video file which would just be
an MP3 file from our mongodb so let's go
ahead and try to test that
and I actually don't have Postman or
anything like that installed on this
laptop at the moment so I'm just going
to use Curl to test this but if you're
familiar with Postman you can use that
to test as well if not just follow along
with the commands that I use and make
sure you have curl installed of course
and at this point we can just go on
YouTube and download a video and we
don't want the video to take too long to
download so we'll just do something
short so this one's 37 seconds
Mark Zuckerberg says he's not a lizard
so we'll just go ahead and take this and
copy the link to the video and I'm going
to use this YouTube download tool to
actually download the video from YouTube
so if you want you can just do Brew
install YouTube DL
and of course it's already installed for
me but that's just in case you want to
do the same thing to get a video or you
can use whatever video you have on your
machine already so I'll just do a
YouTube download and then paste in the
URL for the video
and for some reason that video doesn't
work so let's just try a different one
so yeah sorry Mark
and this video is relatively short so
let's go ahead and do this one
we'll just take the URL
and once that's finished downloading you
should have the file in your current
directory and just really quick we're
going to go into our mySQL database
and we're going to show tables
actually we need to use database auth
and I spelled database wrong
and actually it should just pu's auth so
now we can just show tables and let's
just select all from user
select all from user now when you do
this you should have credentials here
from when we created the database and we
used our SQL script to create the user
in the beginning of this video so you
should have an email and a password and
these are the credentials that we're
going to use in our basic auth when we
send a request to our login endpoint to
get a Json web token to upload the video
so I'm just going to exit this and I'm
going to send a curl request and it's
going to be a post request and I'm going
to send it to http
MP3
converter.com because remember our
Gateway Ingress resolves this host name
and we configured this hostname to
resolve to our local host or our
loopback address so we're just going to
use this when we send requests to our
Gateway and it's going to be the login
endpoint
and in curl you can just do this u-flag
to do basic authentication credentials
and I'll just do Giorgio
email.com
and the password is admin123 for me
and we're actually getting an internal
server error so let's go into canines
and check our Gateway logs and that's
too small so I'll just do Cube CTL logs
f
Gateway
and it's saying in alt service access
dot pylon 16 object has no attribute txt
so we can just go into that file so we
need to change actually we can just go
into the file from here
so it's line 16.
yeah so I'm just going to change
directory
and I'll activate this virtual
environment
foreign
and it's because the response is
response.txt
and not response.txt
and let's just see if there's any more
and let's check the directory for txt
and we should exclude our virtual
environment
so invalidate.pi
so we're going to need to change all of
these
so
I hope there's not too many sorry about
that but of course this requirements.txt
is supposed to be txt and maybe we
should check all of the service
directories because I don't remember
it should be ignoring the virtual
environment there so yeah let's just see
how it goes
so we need to go back into the gateway
and we need to do Docker build again
and then we need to do
cker tag
and this is for the Gateway
and then Docker push
and we'll just delete all of our Gateway
resources
and just recreate them
and it looks like those are up and
running
so let's try to get our token again
and now we were able to successfully get
our JWT
so we can just copy this JWT
and let's go back to the directory where
our video file is so that's in
converter
and here we need to do curl and this is
going to be a post request as well
but this time we need to add our file
and actually to make this easier let's
change the name of this file so we'll
move this
to test.nkv
now we can do curl x post
file equals at test.nkv
and we can't forget the header which
needs to be authorization
and remember it has to be a bear token
and then we'll paste in the token
and that's going to go to our
MP3
converter.com
upload and let's see what happens
and we are getting 403 Forbidden so
let's go ahead and go into canines
and maybe that's coming from our auth
service
let's just check the Gateway nothing
hmm so actually it looks like we're
using the wrong uh host name here we
have MP3 convert but it should be
mp3converter.com let's go ahead and sudo
Vim our hosts
yeah so it should be mp3converter.com so
let's go ahead and try it with that
and let's make sure our tunnel is still
running
and let's see
okay so now we're getting an actual
error from the actual Services I believe
so let's go into canines
and we can assume that that error came
from the Gateway server all right so
we're hitting the server now with our
upload and maybe our Gateway server is
getting an error from auth
but it seems auth is returning a 200 for
the validate so if we're getting the 200
from the validate endpoint on the auth
service
then that means that our Gateway
is returning a an internal server error
when
we get a 200 from validate
so let's change directory into our
Gateway
and go into server.pi
and let's go to validate so for the
upload endpoint
we validate and at some point
I guess we're returning a 500 but
hmm
that's a bit strange
try and
let's get another token really quick
and let's try with the new token
uh and that's because we aren't in the
directory of our file so let's change
directory back to converter where our
test file is and let's try this again
and still an internal server error
so yeah it's a debug this so I'm just
going to scale all of our services down
to just one replica so that we don't
have to check multiple replicas for the
logs
so we can just do Cube CTL scale
and we're going to scale the deployment
Gateway
down to one
and we also need to scale our converter
converter down to one and we also need
to scale our auth service down to one
so when we go into canines now
you can see that we're terminating all
of these extra replicas and we're going
to have one auth service running and one
converter running in one Gateway running
so once that's done terminating
we can go ahead and I'm just going to
open some extra tabs here and run the
logs for our Gateway
and
same for our auth service
and the same for our converter
that's strange there's nothing printing
for the converter so let me see
something
foreign
[Music]
and check the logs so the Gateway is
what's returning the 500
validates returning a 200 so the
validation is going through
and we're not getting anything on the
converter
so if the validation is completing
but the Gateway is still returning to
500 then that means that something's
happening between validation and
actually adding the message and
uploading the file so if we go into our
Gateway server.pi file
we can go to validate and our validation
happens here and it's successful
and we can let's just assume that we're
making it to the upload
and here's where we're returning a 500
so in this case we're catching the error
and we're returning a 500 and we're not
doing anything with the error so we
can't really see what's happening so
let's go ahead and print the error here
and here as well we'll print the error
so then we can see if we're either
getting an error when we're trying to
publish the message
or if we're getting an error when we try
to upload the file
so hopefully we can get some more
information by printing these errors so
we can go ahead and save this and we're
going to need to change directory to
Gateway
and we need to do Docker build and tag
and push again
so we'll do Docker build
because we need to add the code changes
with the print statements and then we'll
do Docker tag and it's going to be the
Gateway repository that we're pushing to
so we'll do username
Gateway latest
and then Docker push
Gateway
and once we've pushed we can just delete
all of our
resources for the Gateway using our
manifest files and then we can just
recreate them
on actually
we don't want to use we don't want it to
scale up more than one right now because
we're debugging so let's do Cube CTL
scale
deployment
to one
and for the Gateway
and let's change directory back to where
our file is
and our logs since we shut down that
container that we were following the
logs for we need to do Cube CTL logs
again for the new container
and let's check our tunnel it's asking
for the password again so we need to do
that
yeah
and let's try this again
so it was a success that time
so I think what was happening was the
old Gateway deployment like the old
replicas weren't connected to the host
because the host variable wasn't
resolving to the actual rabbit and Q
host in the container and that's
something that happens sometimes so
basically like huh let's see if we can
let's see if I can prove what I'm what I
suspect is happening
so for example if we have our rapidm QQ
here
our Gateway is connecting to the
rabbitmq using the name rabbitmq which
is the name of the stateful set so let
me try and clarify
so let's change directory to the Gateway
and if we go into
storage and util.pi
actually not storage util it's just in
server.pi
our connection to rabbitmq we're using
this name rabbitmq which is the name of
the service
because if we
check our rapidmq
manifestservice.yaml you see the name is
rabbitmq
so in kubernetes the service name will
resolve to that Services host
so in server.pi
we're depending on this name resolving
to the host for abadin Q but it seems
that in kubernetes if a container is
connecting to a host via this name if
that host changes or restarts it seems
that the containers that reference that
service name still reference in older
host I believe
so for example if I were to go in here
so first let's send that again uh let's
change directory
to converter and let's send that curl
request again
hmm and we're getting an internal server
error again
but this time
it's not our internal server error so
let's see what's happening
so it says we're referencing
this
error before the assignment hmm
so let's go into Gateway where we did
that
storage util.pi
print error
print
ah here we're not catching the error
for example up here we're doing accept
exception as error
but here we're just doing accept so we
need to do exception as error
foreign
Docker build
and Docker tag
and Docker push
oh actually
that's pretty bad so actually I just did
that in the converter directory so
I basically built the converter image
and pushed it to our Gateway image so I
pretty much just overwrote the Gateway
image with the converter image uh let's
see if we can just cancel that
and let's change directory to Gateway
and now here we can do Docker build but
let me just double check to see what I
did
so yeah I did Docker build in the
converter directory so it built the
docker file within this directory which
is our converter Docker file and then I
pushed it to
the
actual Gateway repository and what did I
change
yeah I made changes to the Gateway
though so Docker build in the Gateway
directory to build our Docker file for
Gateway
Docker tag
Docker push
and now the latest image for our Gateway
repository is going to be this most
recent one so that should resolve the
issue or accidentally pushed the
converter image
and we'll do Cube CTL delete again for
our Gateway resources
and apply
and actually once again I forgot to
scale so scale it to one
foreign
so it looks like that time we got to
success it worked so
so we're still terminating one of the
replicas
mini cubes asking for a password again
because we had to redeploy the Ingress
as well
so
all right so let's go ahead and
set up the logs again for our Gateway
and let's send the request again for the
upload
and again we need to go to where the
file is
and we get a success
auth is successful and the converter is
writing the audio so that's successful
as well
so back to my explanation of what I
think the issue was before
so our Gateway is using the service name
for this rabbitmq service to connect to
that host but I think that if for
example we restart this rabbitmq the
Gateway will still be resolving to the
old host using that rapidmq service name
so the Gateway won't actually be able to
connect if we were to restart this
unless we restart the Gateway which
would refresh its reference to the host
I believe
so let's just try and test that theory
because I don't really like not knowing
what happened so if we send again
we should get a success and then if we
go into canines
and we just delete this pod
so we're going to delete our rabbitmq
pod and it's going to make it restart
and the converter breaks because it's
it needs to connect to the rapidmq host
as well
foreign
so once the rabbit mq pod restarts let's
just restart this one refresh the
converter
now at this point if my theory is
correct the Gateway is still referencing
the older rabbitmq host using the
rabbitmq service name so it's it should
fail if we try to upload right now
so if we do this again
we get an internal server error so if we
reset the Gateway it will reset its
variable for rabbitmq or it will reset
what it resolves rabbit in Q2 which
would be the new host so resetting this
should actually make it work
so now if we do curl upload
we get success so yeah my theory is
pretty much correct and it's kind of
annoying
but yeah just keep that in mind so for
example
let me just
recap what I said
in server.pi we're connecting to our
rabbitmq using the service name
so the service name in kubernetes
resolves to the host so yeah the theory
is that the cluster IP address that this
service name resolves to which is the
cluster IP address of the service the
rabbitmq service the theory is that IP
address changes when we restart the
rabbitm coupon but the Gateway pod still
references the old IP address using this
service name which is why when we
restart the Gateway pod this rabbitmq
its reference for this rabbitmq service
name gets updated which is why it works
after doing that
but anyways the good news is it seems
that everything is working so when we
upload a file we're successfully
if we were to clear this and do
logs for our converter
it seems that we're successfully writing
the audio so in order to confirm that
the end-to-end functionality is working
correctly we can check for the existence
of a audio file from our video
conversion in the DB and that's how
we'll check to see if everything is
working from end to end and also if we
go to our queue let's refresh we can see
that our mp3q has four messages ready
and remember we don't have a consumer
service pulling from the MP3 queue so
all of the messages are just going to
pile up here so at this point we should
have four MP3s in our database and we
uploaded the same video every time so
all four MP3s should be the same audio
file but at this point we should be able
to download one of these four MP3s from
our mongodb and test it to see if it's
working correctly and as you see our
video queue is empty because any message
that we put on the video queue was
processed by our consumer service which
converts them to MP3 and then that
service then puts them onto the MP3
queue so to confirm that everything is
working correctly let's just check our
mongodb to see if we have four MP3 files
which should all be the audio file for
the same video that we uploaded four
times and we can also go ahead and do it
one more time
and we're getting an internal server
error so
let's go ahead and
actually don't remember if we restarted
the Gateway so let's just restart that
just wait till this terminates and we'll
do logs again
for Gateway
and we'll upload that again and we get a
success
so now there should be five messages in
our queue the MP3 queue so as you can
see we now have five messages in the
queue so now we should have five MP3s in
our mongodb database and to test that if
you installed mongodb earlier in this
course you should have [ __ ] shell
which should put you directly into the
mongodb that's running on our local host
or that's running on our local machine
and we should be able to do show
databases and it shows that we have this
MP3s database and this videos database
so this database should have five audio
files stored so let's see if we can just
use MP3s
and now let's try and show collections
and as explained before with grid FS the
actual file data is stored in these
chunks and the files will have a
reference or the file is essentially
like the metadata for a collection of
chunks so if we do DB dot FS dot not
chunks fs.files.find
this will show all of the objects that
we have stored
and actually I forgot that when I was
testing this prior to making this
tutorial I uploaded a bunch of videos
that were converted to mp3s so my
database is going to have more than five
yours should only have the five or it
should only have as many MP3s as you
sent upload requests that were
successful so let's actually do it this
way so we can go to the queue the MP3
queue
and we can actually let's see get a
message from the queue so let's just do
get message
and we see that there's an MP3 file ID
that has this ID
so let's go ahead and copy this
and here we can do DB Dot actually let's
uh show collections again
and we can do db.fs.files.find
and remember we want to use the actual
object version of the ID to find it and
to do that we'll do
underscore ID for the key and then we'll
do object
ID and inside of there we can put our
actual ID and as you can see that actual
object ID is stored successfully inside
of our MP3s database so now what we want
to do is we want to download this and
see if it's an actual audio file and to
do that we can go ahead and exit this
and let's clear and again if you
installed mongodb using the instructions
earlier in this video you should have
this [ __ ] files and you can put for the
DB mp3s and we want to get by ID and we
want the local file to be called we'll
just do test
dot MP3 and we need to use this object
to get the ID same way that we have to
do that within our [ __ ] database so
we'll put that in
which is the string version of the ID
within this object syntax and we should
be able to download the file that way
so it was able to connect to our mongodb
on the local host and it was able to
finish writing to test MP3
so now this test MP3 file should contain
the sound for our video file so it
should contain the sound for this file
so let me just go into this directory on
the user interface okay so now in this
directory which is the directory of our
converter service we have this video
file which is the test MKV file
so here's a burger again the double
double and I'm just going to start
eating away with a bag here and uh
and yeah it's cut that a bit short don't
know about copyright or whatever so this
audio file should be the sound for that
video file so let's go ahead and just as
you can see it's an audio file then we
can just go ahead and play this so
here's the burger again the double
double and I'm just going to start
eating away so yeah it looks like our
end-to-end functionality is working up
to the point where we put the message on
the MP3 queue so at this point we are
uploading our video and adding the
message to a queue so we're essentially
when we upload a video it gets put onto
mongodb then we create a message and add
it to this video queue and then our
consumer converter service is going to
pull off of this video queue convert the
video into an MP3 and then put a new
message on this MP3 queue saying that in
mp3 for a specific file ID exists within
mongodb so the last thing that we need
to create is a service that's going
going to consume This MP3 cue and that
service is just going to be a
notification service that's going to
tell our user that a video is done or a
video conversion to MP3 process is done
so the service is essentially going to
pull the message off the queue and it's
going to have the ID and the email of
the user and it's going to send an email
to the user saying hey this ID is
available for download as an MP3 and
then from there there's going to be a
download endpoint that we create on our
Gateway where the user can use his or
her token to basically request to
download a specific MP3 using the file
ID that's sent in the notification
service email so essentially if you've
gotten to this point where you're
actually having the messages put on the
MP3 queue and the mp3s stored in mongodb
then you've essentially completed the
most difficult part of this entire
tutorial because from there we're just
going to pull messages off this queue
and send an email and that's pretty much
it so if you've gotten this far this is
like a major checkpoint so from here
onward we're just going to create that
additional service and add the code for
the download endpoint on our Gateway
okay so at this point in the tutorial
what we have left is our notification
service and we need to update our
gateway to have a download endpoint so
we can just start by updating our
Gateway and then we'll move on to
creating our notification service after
that so we're just going to change
directory into our Gateway directory and
let's go ahead and clear this and we can
actually close these other tabs that had
our logs
foreign
we can just leave that running for now
and we're going to need to update our
server.pi file so let's go ahead and
open that file and from here we're going
to need to import a couple of additions
so we need to import send file which is
going to be the method that we use to
send files back to the user that
downloads them
and we're going to be pulling that file
from mongodb so just like before we're
going to need to use the binary Json
object ID so we'll import
object ID
and make sure I spelled it right this
time and we're also going to need to
change our configuration for mongodb so
right now we're setting the
configuration for our [ __ ] URI to
include the videos database but that
kind of limits us to just using the
videos database but we need to use both
databases the MP3 and the videos one so
instead of using this configuration this
way we're just going to create two
separate instances of Pi [ __ ] for each
database and if we have a look at the
flask Pi [ __ ] documentation here
essentially what we need to do is this
here
and it says you can create multiple Pi
[ __ ] instances to connect to multiple
databases or database servers so we're
going to do two of these and one's going
to be for our videos database and one's
going to be for our MP3s database
so we're just going to change this to
[ __ ] video
and we can go ahead and
include the URI when creating the
instance
and can't forget the comma here and
we're also going to remove this config
here so we're not going to use this
anymore because we're going to configure
the URI for each instance within the
instantiation of the pi [ __ ] class
so we'll remove that
and for [ __ ] MP3 it's going to be
similar
we'll change this to MP3
and we'll change this to mp3s
and now for grid FS we need to create
two separate FS instances
so this one can be videos
and this will need to be set to [ __ ]
video because we're using the [ __ ]
video instance for the videos fs and
this one can be MP3s
and this will be changed to [ __ ] MP3
and since the old grid FS instance was
referenced by the variable FS we need to
update that so here we're uploading a
video and we were uploading it to the
videos mongodb instance but now we need
to change this to FS videos specifically
and that is all that we need to do for
that
and now we can go to our download
template endpoint that we created and we
can actually write the code for the
download function so we can remove this
pass and we're going to do the same
validation that we do in the upload
endpoint so we can just copy this so
we're going to copy the validate token
request and we're going to copy loading
the access from that variable that
validate token resolves to so we can
just go ahead and copy that part and go
back to our download and paste that in
and we need to add the else here
and actually I just realized we're not
checking the error here in our upload
so let's go back to upload and we need
to do if error so if there's an error
when we try to validate
we need to return
error and let me just check something
really quick
actually no we should be good
foreign
we don't need to have an else
so basically if there is no access then
we're just going to return
not authorized
anyway so the download function is going
to be pretty straightforward we first
need to make sure the file ID exists in
the request so basically the
notification service is going to send an
email to the user informing them that
the conversion job is done and in that
email it's going to give them a file ID
which is the file they should download
when they send a request to the download
endpoint and that file ID is required so
we're going to do
FID string equals request Dot args.get
and it's going to be fid
and basically if this parameter doesn't
exist in the request then it's going to
return none so if we go here we see that
it Returns the default value if the
request data doesn't exist and the
defaults for the default value is none
so we can set this if we want but the
none is the behavior that we want so if
FID doesn't exist in the request then
this FID string will equal none so that
means that we can just do if not FID
string then we can just return FID is
required
oh and I updated the upload endpoint to
handle the error but I didn't update
this one so we'll do if error
return error
and anyways if the FID string does exist
then we're going to use it to get our
file from mongodb so we'll do try
and we'll set out equal to FS MP3s so
this is the mongodb instance for our MP3
database dot get
and remember we need to use the object
ID
which is here and it's a mongodb object
ID and we're importing that here
and to that we're going to pass the FID
string which is essentially going to
convert our FID string to a object ID
which is what's needed to get the object
from mongodb so the data for our MP3
will be referenced by this out variable
so then we can just return
send file
and we'll return out and we'll do the
download name which is going to be the
name of the file and we're just going to
set it to FID string plus MP3
and this is also going to be able to
determine the mime type for the file so
this is all we need to do to return the
file to the client except
exception as error
we'll print the air and we'll return
internal server error
and that's pretty much going to be it
for our download endpoint
so we're just going to get the access
via the validate endpoint from our alt
service
and then we're just going to check to
see if admin is true in that user's
access and if so we're just going to
return the file for the past file ID and
we're not going to check the user's
email or anything in this case we're
just going to assume if they have the
file ID then they have access to the
file but of course feel free to expand
upon this however you like so let's go
ahead and save that and since we changed
the code we need to build this Docker
image again and push it to our
Repository
so we'll do Docker build
and then we'll do Docker tag
and Docker push
and now we can redeploy this so I'm just
going to delete all of the resources for
Gateway just in case so I'll just delete
everything in the Manifest directory
and then I'll just apply them again
and we'll check that later for now we
can just go into creating our
notification service so let's change
directory to our source directory and we
need to make their notification
and we'll CD into notification
so this notification service similar to
our converter service is going to be a
consumer service so we're going to have
some similar code to the converter
service so we're going to copy some
things from our converter consumer.pi
file into our notification consumer.pi
file so let's go ahead and create a file
called consumer.pi
and we're just going to go to our
converter consumer.pi file
and we'll just copy everything over
but we're actually not going to need any
of that and we're also now going to need
any of this but we're going to create a
package called send and a module called
email that we're going to need to import
and this is where we're going to write
the code to send the email
and our callback functions basically
going to stay the same but we are going
to change this to email dot notification
we're going to create a notification
function
and it's only going to take in the body
of the message but other than that the
Callback function is going to be the
same and of course we need to change
this to mp3q because this consumer
service is listening or consuming from
the mp3q
and everything else is going to stay the
same
so now we need to go and create this
function here this email.notification
function
so let's save this file and we'll make a
directory called send and change
directory into send and we'll touch
init.pi
and we're going to create a file called
email.pi
so in this file we're going to write all
of the code to send in email
notification to the client
and we're going to just use this python
documentation here which gives an
example of how to send simple email
messages which is all we really need to
send so our code is going to be similar
to this here
but instead of sending the message via
our own SMTP server we're going to use
Google's SMTP server so we're just going
to send it using the same SMTP server
that Gmail uses and I will show you how
I'm going to do that now so first we
want to import
SMTP lib and Os and for this tutorial
you don't really need to know what an
SMTP server is in simple terms it's just
a server to send receive and relay
outgoing mail between email senders and
receivers so we're essentially just
going to be using the same SMTP server
that Gmail uses within our application
to send emails
so we need to import the SMTP lib and Os
and we also need to import from
email.message
email message
and this is just going to allow us to
create an instance of an email message
and you'll see what I mean by that in a
second so we'll do Define notification
and notification will take in message
from our queue
and then from there we will try and
we'll set message equal to json.loads
the message we're going to turn our
message from our queue into a python
object
and then we'll do MP3 FID equals the FID
in our message
and we need a sender address which is
going to be the address that we're using
to send the email and I'm going to
recommend that you create a dummy Gmail
account to send the email because in
order for this to work within that Gmail
account you're going to need to enable
or authorize non-google applications to
log into your Gmail account so like
basically the default setting when you
create a Gmail is like only Google
applications can log into that account
so for example like the Gmail
application on your phone can log into
that Gmail account but in order for this
application to log into that account
you're going to have to authorize
non-gmail or non-google applications and
that means any non-google application
can log into your Gmail account if they
have your credentials so it's not
recommended that you use your actual
Gmail account for this because I
wouldn't recommend allowing non-google
applications to log into your primary
Gmail account if you want to be safe you
should create a dummy account so the
sender address is going to be the email
address of the Gmail account that you
want to use to send the email so I'm
going to store it in an environment
variable
and the environment variable is going to
be called Gmail address
and then we're going to also do sender
password
and it's going to be in an environment
variable called Gmail password
and I too am going to create a dummy
account for these credentials and I'll
get into that in a little bit and then
the receiver address
which is who we're sending the email to
is going to be the user that's
using
is going to be the user who's associated
with the JWT
because that's the user who uploaded the
original file and then we're going to
create the message that's going to be in
the email it's going to be an instance
of email message and we'll do message
dot set content
and it's just going to be a simple
message it's just going to say
MP3 file ID
and then MP3 fid
which is coming from here
and then is now ready
so then the receiver of this email can
just take the file ID that we give them
and they can send a request to our
download endpoint using this file ID to
download that file and we can just say
the message subject
which is just the same subject that you
would put when you're writing an email
in Gmail and that's just going to be MP3
download
and message from is going to be
sender address
and message two is going to be receiver
address
and lastly we need to create an SMTP
session for sending the mail so
essentially we need to connect to
Google's SMTP server and then log into
our Gmail account and then send the
email so we'll set session equal to SMTP
lib dot SMTP
and we'll put in the Gmail SMTP server
which is smtp.gmail.com
and then we'll do session dot start TLS
and what this does is it puts the
connection to the SMTP server into TLS
mode and TLS is transport layer security
so it's essentially going to make sure
our communication between the SMTP
server is encrypted and this is
essentially to secure our packets in
transit so that they can't be
intercepted and the data within them
read so in simple terms it's just to
secure our communication between our
application and the service you don't
really need to know details about how
this is working either just know that
it's necessary and then after that we're
going to do session.login
and we need to log in using our Cinder
address and sender password
and once we've done that we can do
session dot send message
and in there we're going to put the
message which is the message that we're
instantiating here and we're customizing
that object here and then we're sending
it here
and we're going to put the sender
address and the receiver address and
then once we've sent the message we want
to close the session so we can do
session dot quit and once that's sent we
can just print
male scent
just so that we can see that it's done
and if any of this fails we want to just
print the error so we're in this try
block here
so we'll just do accept exception as
error and then we'll print the error
and then we'll return the error
and the reason we're catching the error
here and returning it is because
the call to this function is expecting
an error so the error should either be
none or it should contain an error
for example so if we go back up One
Directory into our consumer file
we see that notification here
let me close that notification here is
expecting an error and if there is an
error then we're going to send a
negative acknowledgment so the message
can stay on the Queue and be processed
by another process but if there's no
error we're going to send a basic
acknowledgment which means that the
message can be removed from the queue
so that's going to be it for that
and there's a typo here this should just
be session
and there's also no import for Json so
let's do that
and we haven't installed these
dependencies yet either so that's going
to be a problem so we'll just go ahead
and save this
and we can just cat the head of our file
and this file is called email dot by and
we'll do
actually we didn't start a virtual
environment yet so let's change
directory and do Python 3 Dash MV and V
and start our virtual environment
and now we can do fip3 install
actually one second I don't think we
need to install that I think that's
already part of
yeah we don't need to install that
uh let me install this for my Vim
so yeah this is part of Python's
standard Library so we don't need to
install that and let's see if we need
anything installed from consumer.pi we
need to install Pica and that's it so
we'll do pip3 install Pico and that's
going to be it for that so now we can go
ahead and we can actually just copy the
docker file from our Gateway
into this directory
and then we have Docker file and we
don't need to expose anything and this
needs to be changed to consumer.pi and
everything else is going to be exactly
the same so we can just save that
and let's make some space here and we
can also copy the Manifest directory
from our converter.pi
so now we have the Manifest directory
from our converter dot pi and we'll
change the name of converter deploy to
notification deploy.yaml
and we can go into that
notificationdeploy.yaml file and we'll
change all occurrences of converter to
notification
so I just did it using Vim said command
but you can do it however you want just
make sure you change all occurrences of
converter to notification so we want our
deployment name to be notification and
then we want the app label to be
notification and we'll leave replicas
the same and we need to match label
notification as well
and Max surge is going to be the same
and the templates app label is also
going to be notification
and container name also notification and
we're also going to create a Docker
repository called notification as well
and the same for the config map and the
secret
so we can just save that and then we
need to go into our config map and we
need to change this to notification as
well
and the mp3q is MP3 which is correct
and then we need to go into our secret
and this changes to notification and we
don't have a secret here
so let's save that
and let's clear change directory back to
our root now let's go ahead and dock our
build
oh and we forgot to do pip freeze
now Docker build
and Docker tag
foreign
and then notification latest
and now Docker push and notification
latest
and this is going to create the
notification repository in your Docker
Hub account
and now let's check the docker Hub
account
and you should have a repository that
was last pushed a few seconds ago
and if you go to it you should have a
tag latest so the next thing that we
need to do is we need to configure our
Gmail account to allow non-google
accounts to log in okay so I've already
created a dummy Google account or a
Gmail account here so once you've done
the same you want to click on this and
go to manage your Google account
and from here you want to go to security
and you can just go down to the bottom
here and there's this box here that says
less secure app access and I've already
turned this on but you're going to want
to click this and then change it from
off to on
foreign
I'm allowing apps and devices that use
less secure sign-in technology to access
my account
so make sure that this is set to on
before continuing with the tutorial and
another thing that we need to do is well
me specifically if I go to
mySQL U root
and I use auth
and show tables
select all from user
you can see that I'm actually using a
fake email here so the notification
service will try to send an email to
this fake email so if you used a fake
email for your credentials here you
should update it to an actual existing
email I'm just going to send it to my
dummy email so I'll essentially be
sending the notification to myself but
you can send the email to whatever email
you want to use because at that point
that email is just receiving a message
so it's not insecure to use an actual
legitimate email for the actual sent
message
so I'm just going to update mine
so if I go ahead and select all from
user again
you can see that my email has now
changed
and that's actually the email that I'm
using here
so I can just exit this and that means
that I'm going to have to get another
token when we test this later on and you
will have to do the same if you've
changed the email
and let's just go ahead and clear so at
this point we can go ahead and deploy
the notification service so we can just
do Cube CTL apply everything in the
Manifest directory
and we can check this
and it looks like it's working as
expected
and we could just change directory to
our source directory and actually let's
scale up our Gateway and our auth
service as well
so I'll just apply all
manifests
and that's going to scale it up to the
two replicas that we have configured in
our manifest directory for the all
service
and we can do the same thing for Gateway
and Gateway has two instances deployed
as well
and the same thing for converter
so that's scaling our converter up to
four instances
so at this point we have everything we
have two instances of our auth service
four instances of our converter two
instances of our Gateway four instances
of our notification service and one
instance of our rapid mq service so now
let's just check to see if our tunnel is
running it's asking for the password
again because I redeployed the Gateway
Ingress so I'll put the password in and
our tunnel is running and now I'm just
going to go ahead and log in again
but this time I'm going to change the
email so gmail.com
63 and let's see if we can get the token
okay so now we have a token which I will
just copy
and now I'm going to send and upload
request so let me see if I have I need
to go to converter
and I'll delete the test MP3 that I had
from last time
and I'll upload the
test MKV file
but I'm going to change this token
so this is going to be the curl request
to upload the video file
so what we're doing right now is we're
testing the end-to-end functionality
including the notification service so
we're first uploading a video so this is
the curl request to upload this video
and the header authorization bear is
going to be the token that I just got
from the login into point
and then our upload URL
and I'm assuming this is because we need
to restart our Gateway service
so I'll just delete both of these
so they can restart
and let's try again
and we have a success
so if everything's working as expected
the message should be being consumed
from our MP3 queue as well
so let's just restart this and it says
we have six unacknowledged now let me
check this email
Ah that's because I forgot a very
important part
so let me change directory
to the notification service
actually I didn't forget so what is the
issue
okay so for some reason we're
experiencing an issue so
let's just check the logs for our
notification service
just send it again
okay
I'm going to scale everything down
Gateway converter
all
notification
actually I'm just going to scale
everything down to zero and restart it
so the only thing I have up right now is
the rabbit in QQ
and now I'll scale everything up to one
okay so let's try and send the request
and now
so it seems that somehow the messages
aren't being acknowledged
actually there's one more thing that I
forgot so
I need to go into our notifications
manifest secret file and we need to set
up our Gmail address environment
variable and Gmail password
so we can just use this placeholder and
change it to Gmail address
and Gmail
password
and that's because if you remember
in our notifications send email dot Pi
file
here we set our sender address to an
environment variable and we also set the
sender password here to an environment
variable
so we need to provide those credentials
here so I'm going to do my credentials
and you need to do the ones for the
account that you're using
foreign
and make space and just to be safe I'm
just going to scale everything down
so I'm scaling everything aside from the
queue down to zero
and then I will scale it back up
actually
for the notification service
I need to reapply
so I'll just remove the resources first
and this is for notification
and then I will reapply those
and let me check to see if those
variables are working as expected
and they are working as expected so
let's see if that resolved the issue
so let's just go ahead and send again
but
it's in our converter directory
foreign
so it seems that it's still not getting
acknowledged so it seems that the
messages are being consumed from the
queue so the issue has to be in our
notification service
within the consumer.pi code
there's probably an issue
so we're consuming the message but we're
never acknowledging the message but
we're never acknowledging that we've
processed the message
so our email that notification
we basically have everything in this try
block
and if there's an issue we're printing
the error and returning the error
[Music]
okay so we need to make a small change
to our notification
send email dot Pi file
so here we need to add in the port 587
and this is the port for TLS and start
TLS so I'm thinking that this should
resolve the issue that we're having so
I'll go ahead and save this
and then we could just do Docker build
and actually we're in the wrong
directory so
let's do Docker build
and Docker tag
and Docker push
and while that's pushing let's check the
queue So currently since we had those
unacknowledged messages in our queue and
our notification consumer service isn't
currently consuming because we scaled it
down we had messages that were ready but
they just got swallowed up by the
service
and it seems that they're getting
acknowledged at this point so this
should go down to zero all right so they
were all processed so that means that we
should have emails for all of those
messages so if I go to the inbox here
you can see that we have the emails for
the messages
and let me check spam
and I think some of those messages had
the old email the one that wasn't a real
email so that's why I only we're not
getting 11 messages we're only getting
these ones
but anyways the email contains the MP3
file ID string here so we should be able
to take this and use it to download the
actual file
so we can clear this and to download the
file we're going to do curl and we want
the output of the file to go to a file
so we'll just name that file download
MP3 download.mp3
and it's going to be a get request and
the header is going to contain our
authorization and it's going to be the
authorization token
and the URL should be mp3converter.com
and don't need the port
and it should be the download endpoint
and you should put a URL query parameter
here that's called FID and set it equal
to the ID from the email
so my email ID is
this ID here which is the same ID that
I'm using here
and then if you hit enter on that it
should download the file
and now you should have a file in the
directory called MP3 download.mp3 and we
should be able to open this file up or
listen to this file and it should be the
video that we uploaded to audio so let
me just go to that in the user interface
so as you can see I have this file here
called MP3 download.mp3 and if I play it
so here's a burger again the double
double it will play the sound from the
video that we uploaded so that means
that our end-to-end application is
working and let's just clear here and we
don't need this
so let's quickly go into canines and we
have everything scaled down so let's
just reapply the initial configuration
so I'm just going to delete the
configuration
for all of our services
except for the rapidmq of course because
no need to scale that up or down there's
only one pod for that
and then now we can just apply
auth manifests
converter manifests
Gateway
and notification
and now if we go into here
we have all of the instances that we
have configured for our services
so let's just move that video file from
converter
let's just move that here and let's
check our cue really quick so currently
our queue is empty
and let's go ahead and upload this file
actually let me make sure I have a valid
token so
I'll just do
a request to the login endpoint to get
the token
and there's the new token so I'll just
try to upload
and let's just Spam it a couple of times
so it seems that our cues are processing
both the videos and the MP3 messages and
at this point it seems that they're all
done and if we go into our email we have
a few more downloads here so we can just
go ahead and copy the file ID for one of
those
and now we can just go ahead and attempt
to download that
we'll do a different name for the file
so I'll just put something random just
something dot MP3
and let's change this to the file ID
that we just copied from the email
whoops that's the JWT let me go copy
that again
and let's download
and we have this file something.pi so
let me go to the user interface and play
that so in our source folder we have
something.pi
so here's a burger and as you can see it
is working as expected and that is going
to be it for this tutorial I think that
if you were able to make it to the end
of this tutorial and you were able to
get everything working you should
definitely be proud of yourself because
this one was a difficult one and yeah if
you have any questions feel free to post
them in the comment section I'll try to
help you as best I can if you're having
troubles getting everything working and
I hope that this has been helpful to you
and if you've made it this far in the
video and if you haven't already please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the channel for more
content like this and yeah I'll see you
in the next one